hello welcome to learn Swift programming
for beginners lesson 1 today we're gonna
talk about variables you're gonna learn
about what they are how to declare them
in Swift code and furthermore how to use
them alright so let's get started for
the rest of the lessons in this series
we're going to be working inside this
app called Xcode Xcode is the tool that
Apple has provided for people to build
apps with and inside Xcode you're going
to be able to create your user
interfaces you're going to be able to
write the code to express the logic in
your app you're going to be able to test
your app even so that's why this is
where we're going to start in learning
Swift we're gonna be writing the Swift
code inside the app that you're actually
going to use to build apps with in the
future so this is where you're gonna get
Xcode just go to your browser go to
developer.apple.com / Xcode or you can
launch the Mac App Store on your
computer and search for Xcode there if
you're on the webpage you can see that
there's this big blue download button up
top now ideally you want to make sure
you're using the latest version of Xcode
and right now as of this recording it's
8 and you can check your version if you
go to Xcode you can see it here in the
welcome screen and you can also go up
here to Xcode about Xcode and you can
see what the version is if you're a PC
user and you're running Windows there
may be some additional work you need to
do before you can run Xcode or you might
have to use an alternative solution to
build iOS apps so check in the
description below for PC solutions
however if you are a PC user don't let
that discourage you for me personally I
lost about 2 to 3 years of learning iOS
development simply because I didn't have
a Mac and I didn't want to get a Mac but
these days there are alternative
solutions you don't actually have to buy
a Mac computer although I eventually did
and now I haven't looked back so anyways
now that you have Xcode and after you've
installed it it's a pretty large install
it's pretty big program so I might take
some time but after you have it
installed and you launch it you're going
to see this welcome screen you can see
here that when you want to create an app
for iPhone iPad Mac or whatever you're
going to go to
create a new Xcode project and that's
gonna start a full-out project for you
to build an app in but here we're gonna
start a new playground because that's
gonna allow us to type some code quickly
it's gonna let us run that code and see
the results and we're not committing to
building in a project it's simply like a
sandbox or a playground as its named now
if you don't see this welcome screen
what you can do is just go up to file
new and hit playground right there and
that's going to start a new playground
for you as well or you can just hit this
button get started with a playground so
that's gonna launch this dialog for you
and I'm simply going to leave the
default name there platform should be
iOS and I'm going to save this on my
desktop okay so after your playground
runs you'll see up here it's doing a
whole bunch of stuff a launching
simulator getting it ready and when it's
done all that it's going to say ready
you can already start typing in code so
there you go it says ready but when it
doesn't say ready and it's doing
something then chances are whatever
you're typing here is not going to show
up on the right-hand side okay we're
going to start with a quick tour of this
playground window here so down on the
left hand side I have a bunch of line
numbers now if you don't have these and
you want them they can be useful at
times especially when I'm teaching and I
need to refer to line numbers you can go
to Xcode preferences and you can go to
text editing and you can simply enable
line numbers there now this area right
here is where we're going to type our
Swift code and it's already got a bunch
of stuff for us right here which we're
going to go through in a second on the
right hand side you're going to see a
quick preview of the results of what you
typed there now a lot of people have
trouble with getting output to show up
on this right-hand side based on what
they type here well one of the things
that you can check is just in this
status bar up here make sure that it
says ready and as you're typing
something let's say I change something
like that you're going to see that it
for a brief second there there was a
little spinner because it's evaluating
your code here if you wanted to show up
just make sure it says ready to process
your next command and you know you
should see that output there
alternatively there is a tray down here
which you may not notice because it's
hidden at first you can hit this button
to show the debug area or there's also
this little button here to hide the
different panels okay but we don't need
to see all of that but this debug panel
may be useful when we start to output
things here this is called a console
area where we can use swift commands to
output things this blue icon here is to
execute the code in your playground so
if you can't get things to show up on
the right here try clicking this button
to run your playground right now it's
blue because you can see there's a
little drop-down arrow there if you
click and hold it you can see whether
you want to switch it to automatically
run and that's going to run the
playground whenever you type something
or you can set it to manually run and
you can see now it's grayed out so if I
type in some new code it's not actually
going to change or display what I have
on the right-hand side here unless I
click the play button to run it so I
would recommend to have it set to
automatically run so now that you know
in the main areas of the playground
let's get into the meat of today's topic
variables and in fact what we have here
is a variable in Swift a variable hold
some data now this data could be a value
it could be a reference to an object or
it can even point to a function which
are things that will get into the future
but for now we're going to say that
variables hold theta now as you can see
from this example line of code a
variable has a couple of distinct parts
let's break it down variables need to be
declared before they can be used so this
VAR keyword is used to declare a new
variable following the VAR keyword you
have the variable name in this case it's
STR and really that's it you've declared
your new variable so it's got the VAR
keyword and it's gotten the variable
name now taking a look at the whole line
what we have on the right hand side
there that's some data we did say that
variables
hold data right in that equal sign in
between the variable name and the piece
of data well that's an assignment
operator so what we're doing in this
line of code is we're declaring a
variable called STR and then we're
assigning that piece of data to that
variable so now jumping back into the
playground let's see the effect of that
I can say something like print which is
a keyword that is going to print
something to that console area down
below so if I say print and then in the
parentheses I put STR you can see that
it's printed that hello play out s ruff
lying down there on the right hand side
we can see a quick preview of that and
notice that there's a /n here and that
is basically just denoting that there's
a newline associated with that print
statement because the next time I print
something it's going to be printed on
the next line so you don't see that here
because a newline is just a carriage
return or whitespace you can't really
see it but in here in this preview it's
visualized as that /n which is just a
newline so let's take a look at a couple
of different pieces of data that we can
store in two variables so I'm going to
declare another variable here called a
and I'm going to assign a number into it
so just var one and I'm going to declare
another one called B which I'm going to
also assign one and I want to show you
that you can perform operations between
the variables or on the variables so for
example I can say print a plus B and you
can see here that the result in the
console here is two now notice that what
I'm using the variables in an equation
or an operation like this I don't need
to use the keyword var because that's
only for declaring variables alright so
this little part is declaring the
variable but when you use them
afterwards you just need to refer to
them by name so let's try some other
things
print A - B I'm print a times B okay so
variables hold data and you can perform
operations on variables now you can
change the data that the variable is
holding so I can say something like a
equals two now right in fact actually
let's not do it down here let's do it
here after we've assigned one into a
let's say a equals two and as a result
you can see all of these operations have
changed because a is now two so a plus B
is three a minus B is one and so on
because a is now two now when you assign
something into a a different piece of
data it replaces what it was holding on
to before so a is no longer one it is
now two but notice how when we assign a
new piece of data into a we don't have
to write var again that would cause an
error because we've already declared
that variable up here in memory in the
system has been allocated to it and so
we don't need to read eclair it all we
need to do is assign new data into a
like that
now if you're playing around in the
playground yourself you may notice
something like what if you try to assign
something into STR like one well you're
gonna get an error and that's because of
something called data types which we're
going to learn them out in the next
lesson but for now just know that for
STR because we've assigned some text
into it up there if we want to reassign
some data into it again it has to be
text as well so that would be valid
furthermore you can also assign a
variable as another variable so I can
say a equals B down here and in that
case a would now equal one again well it
was one to begin with so let's say I did
that
so if a was two and then I said
equals B then now they would both be one
now before we move on a quick note on
naming variables here we have a variable
STR and I've named some variables a and
B so normally you want name variables
like a and B because they're not
descriptive of the data that they hold
so if you're going to be using variables
just like this in an operation wouldn't
it be easier if you knew what a
represented and won't be represented
well you can declare your variables
using any sorts of names that you would
want but you can't put some special
characters and you can't put spaces in
your variable name however the common
practice is to use a form of camelcase
where the first letter is lowercase so
let me show you what I mean so I can say
var and if I want to describe my
variable if it represents let's say the
number of apples that I have I would say
something like my number of apples like
that and you can see that each new
letter of each word is capitalized
except the first one now you don't want
to get too crazy with the length of the
variable name as well and you don't want
to go too short so short that it doesn't
actually mean anything so there's no
right or wrong answer or hard limits
it's based on you know your own
preference and it's more important if
you're working in a team with other
people that you agree on a certain
coding style because you're both going
to be working on the same code ok so one
more thing I want to talk about our
constants so they are like variables
except that once you assign something to
them you can't reassign data into them
so that's really the only difference
that and also how they're declared
so with variables you use the keyword
var but with constants you use the
keyword let so I can say let C equals 10
and then down here if I try to reassign
something into C like that Xcode is not
gonna like that and it's gonna throw an
error and it's gonna tell you with this
red dot down here and if you click it
it's gonna say cannot assign value to C
because it's a left constant now it
gives you this little bubble here what
you can click and smartly it's gonna
change let to var because it senses that
you want to reassign data into it so you
might ask why would I ever want to use a
constant if it's more limited in its
functionality right if I declare
everything as variables then I have the
all the flexibility I had one well there
are a couple of reasons why you'd want
to use constants when it makes sense for
one thing it helps the computer work a
little more efficiently because it knows
exactly what that constant will be and
that's not going to change but more
importantly it's that for you as a coder
you know that that constant isn't going
to change because when you're building
your app you're gonna have a lot of
variables and when you have some sort of
issue in your app and you don't know why
it's happening and you're tracking down
your code you're tracing it line by line
and you're trying to see if maybe at
some point you've accidentally assigned
something to a variable and that's
throwing off all your calculations or
all over your logic it's going to be a
nightmare to try to solve and untangle
so if something you know it isn't gonna
change you can assign it to a constant
and then when you're looking through
your code you can be sure that the issue
doesn't lie with that constant because
you know it can't change okay so that's
it for this lesson on variables I hope
you're practicing on your own computer
with Xcode and check below this video
for a link to the cheat sheet and the
notes hello welcome to learn Swift for
beginners lesson 2 in this lesson we're
going to talk about data types did you
know in the previous lesson that you are
already working with different data
types well let me point it out to you
let me open up the playground that we
were working with in the previous lesson
do you remember how we were trying to
reassign data into the variable STR and
I was assigning something like a number
into STR and I told you that you
couldn't do that in fact Xcode tells you
that you can just do that right here so
if we take this little console area and
we scroll the scroll bar all the way up
to the top the error message actually
tells you what's going on cannot assign
value of type int to type string well
what's an INT and what's a string well
those are two examples of datatypes just
as the name implies a data type is a
classification or a type of data for
example a string is a data type that
described pieces of text and int short
for integer is a data type for whole
numbers negative or positive however
there are many more data types than just
these two other types of data that
you'll commonly be working with are
float for floating-point numbers or
decimal numbers and then there's double
for decimal numbers where the decimal
portion may be very large and then
there's boolean which represents true or
false or in other words yes or no these
are some of the more common data types
that you'll be using and the reason why
there are different types of data is
because the system stores different
types of data and differently and so
when we go back to the playground and we
take a look at this variable that we
declared here STR and it stores a string
the system has allocated this variable
to store this piece of text or string in
other words and when you try to assign
an INT into that same variable it
doesn't allow you to do that because
strings and intz are stored differently
now you might be wondering what
differentiates a variable that stores a
string like this STR variable versus a
variable that stores a number or an int
like this variable a well when you
declare a variable you learned in the
previous lesson
that you use the keyword var and then
the name of the variable well optionally
you can also put beside the variable
name colon followed by the data type and
if you declare your variable this way
you're basically telling the system that
this variable can only store this type
of data and if you omit that part and
you just simply declare your variable
with var and then the variable name then
what it's gonna do is as soon as you
assign a piece of data into that
variable it's going to take a look at
what type of data that is and assumes
that that variable stores that data type
so now going back into the playground
here it's as if we declared this st our
variable like this right and these ones
are like this now for instance if I
declared this STR variable like this
then this line would be an error because
I'm trying to assign a string into a
variable that is of type int so it's not
going to like that now let's change this
back to a string for a second and go
back to this line where there's an error
now you understand why this line is in
red because we can't assign an int into
a string variable well there are ways to
convert data from type to type in some
cases it makes sense like 29 here this
in can be represented as a piece of text
simply like that right but conversely
this hello playground line right here
I can't convert that to an integer
because it doesn't make sense that this
message could be represented by a number
so for example just as a little preview
here if I wanted to convert this number
or this integer into a string
I would create any string and pass in
the number like that now I'm not gonna
go into detail about why this works or
what this line is because then you're
gonna have to learn about classes and
initializers and stuff like that but for
now in this lesson I want you to
understand that there are different data
types why there are different data types
and how that comes into effect when
you're declaring your variables and
working with your variables and your
data now before we end this lesson off
let me just show you a couple of
examples of the other data types we
talked about so float could be something
like that a double usually also looks
like this and you're not going to have a
really large decimal point unless it's
like a result of a calculation that
you're doing and let me show you a
boolean which is represented as bull so
you can set this to the keyword true or
false which is going to come in handy
for the next lesson that we're going to
do on if statements oh and there is a
mistake here because I'm read éclairs e
did you see that in the previous lesson
we talked about how you can tree declare
a variable C we declared VAR c up here
but i forgot that we had tried to
declare a constant with the same name
down here so this is going to have to be
f i'll show you some other types of data
conversions here so i can say let's
print out
let's change c which is a float into an
INT and what's going to happen is that
it just drops the decimal portion of
that so if you did print let's convert d
which is a double into an integer you
can see here that it just chopped off
the point 9 and you get 13 now there is
a rounding function which we can try out
right now like that and then inside the
parentheses you can put d which is our
double 13.9 and what you're going to get
as soon as it finishes processing is 14
like that but notice that the result is
also
a decimal number see it has a point zero
there so what you can do is wrap the
result of that rounding inside a pair of
brackets like this inside an INT and
then you'll get 14 without the decimal
okay so that does it for data types
hello welcome to learn Swift for
beginners lesson 3 in this lesson you're
going to learn how to express some
simple decision making in your Swift
code using if statements all right let's
get started so for this one we're going
to start a brand new playground alright
so we've done this before let's just
call this one the if playground and I'm
going to store this on my desktop
ok so we're talking about if statements
today and this is really exciting
because it lets us finally start to make
decisions through code and express some
sort of logic so for example if I have
let's declare a constant here so let a
equals 10 for example and I wanted to
print this statement only if a is less
than let's say 11 which it is right here
but mmm okay actually that is that is
not right let's say 4 and this gives us
a reason to use the if statement right
ok
so print only if a is less than 4 but a
is 10 right so we shouldn't be
outputting this so what we can use here
is an if statement and what it allows us
to do is only execute some code if a
certain condition is true so in this
case we want to print this only if a is
less than 4 so we can write an if
statement too
check if that's true or not before we
print that statement so let me show you
what that syntax looks like and if
you're not familiar with programming
terms syntax is simply like the
grammatical structure of the language so
it's basically the key words to use and
how we go about declaring an if
statement or writing an if statement so
it all starts with the if keyword
following the if keyword we have the
condition in which we want to check and
following the condition we have a set of
curly brackets now inside the curly
brackets that's where we put the code
that we want to run if that condition is
true so that's your very basic if
statement now going back to our
playground let's write it out and print
this only if a is less than four so we
can do something like that if a and then
we can use this operator less than four
and remember we need to surround the
piece of code that we want to execute if
the condition is true using a pair of
curly brackets like that so you can put
the curly bracket on the same line or
you can put it on a second line it
doesn't matter but what you usually want
to do is indent the code that is inside
it it's just so it's easier to read I
usually like to put this curly bracket
in the same line like that okay so now
you can see that in the console there's
nothing printed and also to the right
here it doesn't give you a preview
because this condition is false a is not
less than four because a is ten now what
if we changed a to one and let the
playground process okay now it prints
this statement and it previews this
statement see it's printed down here so
that's your very basic if statement now
there are other cool things that you can
do with an if statement there is an else
if Clause so for example using the else
if clause you can check a sec
condition if the first condition
evaluates to false and the syntax for
that looks like that so you have your if
condition and then you have your curly
brackets and then you use the key words
else if and then you check another
condition and you have another set of
curly brackets so if you write it this
way you're basically checking condition
number one you know is that true if it's
false
now you're checking condition two and if
that actually evaluates to true then
you're running the code inside that else
if block now keep in mind that it kind
of goes from top down and if the first
condition is actually true then it's
gonna run that piece of code inside the
first set of curly brackets and it's
just gonna ignore your else if statement
so let's take a look at that inside the
playground so here I'm gonna put else if
a is less than let's say eight then now
I'm going to print only if a is less
than eight so now I'm gonna change just
not this I'm gonna change a back to ten
here and you can see nothing gets
printed because first it checks this
condition if it's false which it is then
it's gonna check this condition and it's
also false so nothing gets printed now
what if I changed a to seven now if I
change the a to seven you can see that
it prints the second statement because
first it checks this condition that's
false so now it checks this condition
and that actually turned out to be true
so it's going to run this line of code
here however if a is 1 then it checks
this first one and then it prints this
one and then it totally ignores all of
the other else if conditions now I said
all of the other else if conditions
right
I say that because you can have as many
else--if conditions as you want so you
can say if a US is less than ten and
then you can you can continue adding as
many conditions as you want but keep in
mind that it checks from top to bottom
and as soon as it finds a condition that
is true it's going to run that piece of
code and ignore all of the other
conditions now finally there is a clause
that you can run if all of the
conditions are true kind of like as a
fail-safe or as a last resort and that
is the else keyword so the way you write
this is using the else keyword it's not
else if it's just simply else and
there's no condition attached because if
all of the conditions above it are false
then it's going to run the code inside
of this else statement here so going
back to the playground let me show you
what that looks like
else print nothing was true and now let
me change a back to ten here so you can
see that it prints nothing was true
because it's checking the statement it's
false this statement is false and sorry
I mean conditions and this condition is
also false because a is not less than
ten a is actually ten so this would
actually evaluate to false and finally
it just gets to this else Clause and
it's going to print what's in here okay
so let me show you a couple of other
things that you can do with L statements
and let's change these print statements
to something that is a lot more
recognizable or easy to read let's do
that branch one branch two and here oops
branch three
okay so first of all let me show you how
to do less than or equal to now you see
it prints branch three so that's how you
do less than or equal to and likewise
you can do greater than or equal to and
you can see here it's still prints
branch three now what if you wanted to
check if it was exactly ten you wouldn't
do that because remember this equal sign
is an assignment operator so what you
need to do to compare if a is equal to
ten
you use the double equal sign like that
you can see here it prints branch three
okay so why don't we introduce another
constant up here let's say B and let's
have that equal to four I want to show
you that your conditions for your if
statements and your different branches
can get pretty complicated and you can
involve multiple pieces of data in your
condition so you can go if a is less
than four if you want to check B as well
and you want to say you know and B is
less than four that's how you would do
it you would use this double ampersand
sign and now you're checking two
conditions you're checking is a less
than four end B less than four and only
if both of those are true are you going
to get this branch here so let's try
that out so if I set B to 1 and a 2 1
then both of these conditions here are
true so it's gonna print branch 1
however if I set B to 10 all right it's
going to just see it hits this branch
too now because a is 1 which is less
than 8 and it didn't print branch 1
because this was false right even though
a is 1 and this part is true we have to
have this part to be true as well
because were you saying is a less than 4
and B less than 4 in
is ten right now however you can also do
or so you can say is a less than four or
be less than four and in this case
either condition can be true and that
would cause it to go into this branch so
you can see now it is in branch one
alright so let's say a is ten and B is 1
so a is not less than four but B is
right because you're using this or
statement you're saying is a less than 4
or B less than 4 and if that's true then
we're coming into here now furthermore
if you wanted to involve let's do a C
you can combine you know multiple
conditions like this you can put this
into a pair of parenthesis like this and
you can say you know and C is equal to 3
so you can see now that you're saying
okay is a less than 4 or B is less than
4 and also is C equal to 3 then come
into branch 1 now these brackets matter
a lot because what you're doing is
you're saying that this has to be true
and this has to be true but for example
if I just shift the brackets a little
bit and I say something like this then
that changes the meaning completely
because now I'm saying is a less than 4
or is this part true right so where your
brackets are matter a lot and it changes
the meaning of what you're checking did
you get that in this case I am checking
is this true or is this true but the
other way around
I'm checking is this true and is this
true all right so the brackets matter
finally let me show you another operator
that we have here so here we have we're
checking is C equal to 3 well what if we
want to ask is see anything but 3 or is
C not equal to 3 if we only care about
the case where C is not 3 we can say
something like this not equals to 3 and
this is going to say is C not equal to 3
so you can see here that C is 3 so
that's why it it completely skips this
branch and it ends up being a is equal
to 10 and it prints branch 3 now you can
use this not operator this exclamation
mark here on other things as well so for
example here I'm asking is a equal to 10
right and I am it's coming in here
because a actually is 10 and so it's
printing branch 3 but if I surround this
like that let me put something else's in
here is a equal to 10 and B equals to 1
right that is true so that's why I'm
still getting branch 3 but if I put an
exclamation mark here like that
it basically flips it around so this
evaluates to true right a is a 10 this
evaluates to true both the this whole
condition evaluates to true right 8 is a
equal to 10 and B is equals to 1 and
then so we get true but then we're
adding this guy here it flips that true
to a false so that's why this whole
condition equates to false ok so that
does it for if statements I hope you're
trying this out on your own computer in
the
lay around because trust me it's
pointless to try to memorize all of the
keywords and the syntax for the swift
it's much better if you you know only
spend thirty minutes instead of trying
to memorize things spend 30 minutes in
the playground just punching in
different numbers like that playing
around with the different conditions and
expressions and printing out a bunch of
stuff in the console in 30 minutes
you'll remember a lot more just by doing
that then trying to memorize you know
how to declare a variable or how to
declare an if statement so you know if
you can get a Mac get Xcode open in a
playground and then type this code out
for yourself and and play around with it
it's going to do wonders so thanks again
for watching and if you like the series
so far please give the video a thumbs up
please subscribe it really helps hello
welcome to the learn Swift for beginners
series lesson 4 in this lesson you're
going to learn about switch statements
and like the if statement it allows you
to make decisions with your code alright
so let's get started let's start by
creating a new playground for this
example and I'm gonna start labeling
these after the lessons here and I
should have done this sooner but I want
to point out that Apple does have a
swift programming language guide and in
this guide it goes through all of the
syntax and the structure and the
different concepts of the Swift
programming language it's what we're
doing in these videos and more in fact
so if you want something to read you can
go ahead and visit this website here
I'll have the link below the video but
one thing to note is that it may be a
little bit complicated for the absolute
beginner who doesn't have programming
background but give it a try and it's a
great compliment to watch with this
learn Swift series that you're watching
in fact as we're going through the
different concepts and these videos I'll
point out in the guide where they are so
for example we're looking at the switch
statement today and that resides under
control flow and you can see here what
the basic syntax is for this
which statement okay so let's jump back
into our playground and we can do an
example of a switch statement so in here
I'm going to basically do the same
example or similar example as the one in
the guide and I'm going to introduce a
new data type called character and it's
basically like a string except that it's
just a single character like that and
with an if statement we can do something
like this if some character is you know
equals mm a for example okay like we
have right here print is in a and this
is going to be true and it's gonna print
this out and then we're gonna have else
if and we're going to maybe check
another condition if we wanted to you
know respond to different cases
depending on what letter this variable
is right but you can use a switch
statement and it looks like this so we
start with the switch keyword then you
have the value which you're considering
in our case that value is in the
variable some character so that's what
we would put in there and then you open
up a pair of curly brackets inside these
curly brackets you have different case
labels so you would have case if you
wanted to consider the case where the
value is an A you would have case a and
then you have colon and you would have
something to do if it were that case
perhaps this would be easier to
visualize if we take a look at the
playground so let's jump back to the
playground here so let me say switch
statement right on the value that we're
considering so that's some character and
you open up a pair of curly brackets
like that and then you have your case
labels so I have case you know if it's
an A and if I want to do something for
this case right then you have a colon
and in here you would print it's a is an
a like that and if there's another case
right I would have case
be for example and I would say is a B
and lastly if none of those cases are
true I would have a default case like
that and I would say print mmm some
fallback
so in this switch statement this case
was true right so it printed out this
statement and it doesn't do the rest and
you can have more lines of code in here
than just the print statement in all of
our examples you know I just wanted to
show that it's coming into here this
branch but you could execute more code
in here now the case where you know
character is a B then we would come into
here and jump into here now if it's not
none of those cases we would have
default and it would print that and of
course you can have a whole bunch of
different case labels it just doesn't
have to be the two that we have here and
the benefit of using a switch statement
is that rather than using an if
statement and having all of these else
if clauses reading this is much more
clean and it's a lot easier to read as
well so what if you wanted let's say two
different cases to run the same piece of
code or the same block of code so for
example if I change this to say is B or
you know a C is a B or C I could do
something like this with this case label
here I can do that comma and then I can
put this other case there so this saves
me from having to have another case C
and then you know the same code I can
put a comma here put the other case here
and have either one of these cases use
the same block of code so now you can
see that it comes into this case here
prints is a B or C instead of coming
into default so why would you want to
use a switch statement over an if
statement well if there are a lot of
different conditions that you want to
check on
a certain value rather than using an if
statement with a whole ton of else ifs
you can use this switch statement which
is easier to read and easier to
understand you're probably going to use
the if statement more than the switch
statement but it's still a handy tool to
have in your arsenal so I highly
recommend that you try this out in your
playground so that's it for switch
statements this is a short one I hope
you enjoyed it please help this channel
grow by subscribing and hitting that
thumbs up button below the video hello
welcome to learn Swift for beginners
lesson 5 in today's lesson we're going
to talk about loops when you're writing
your app there's going to be many times
you're gonna find yourself needing to
repeat pieces of code for instance let's
say you're showing five things in your
app and you need to turn each of them
red so a loop is going to allow you to
just write that single line of code to
turn something red and you can repeat it
five times for each of those five
objects and that's going to save you
from having to write out that code five
times so that's a very simplified
example but trust me you're going to use
them a lot so let's take a look at how
to use them so there are three types of
loops we're going to cover today we're
gonna start with the for in loop as you
can see in the Swift programming guide
here so let's go ahead and start a new
playground in our Xcode and I'm just
going to call this the loop playground
and save it on my desktop now a
for----in loop allows you to repeat a
piece of code a certain specified number
of times if you have a list of data
otherwise known as an array which you're
going to learn about in an upcoming
lesson you can also use a for in loop to
go through each of those pieces of data
in that array and execute some sort of
code on it so this is perfect for the
example we mentioned in the intro about
having five objects or five items on the
screen
and you need to turn each of them red
for example so let's start with learning
how to use a four end loop to repeat a
piece of code for a specified number of
times and when you guys learn about
arrays I'll show you how to use a
foreign loop to go through each piece of
data in that array so as you can see
true to its name the key words to use
here are four and in so you start with
the keyword 4 and next you have a
variable name now you don't have to
declare this variable using the VAR
keyword like you've learned in the
previous lessons you can simply have a
name for this variable because you're
only going to refer to this variable
within the for in loop this variable
that you specify here is going to keep
track of which iteration of the loop is
currently running next up you have the
keyword in and then you have the lower
range followed by dot dot dot and then
the upper range and that last part there
after the in keyword is the range which
your for loop is going to run in and
it's inclusive of those numbers so for
example if you have one dot dot dot 5
it's actually going to run 5 times and
then after that you open a set of curly
brackets and inside the set of curly
brackets that's where you're going to
put the code that you want to repeat for
that number of times so let's jump back
to the playground and let's do a quick
demo on that for in loop so I have the
for keyword here and for my variable I
can specify something like index and
then I would put in and let's use that
same example 1 2 5 and then I open up a
set of curly brackets and in here I'm
simply going to print hello and we're
going to see this in the console down
here it is printed at 5 times now part
of the reason why you specify a variable
name here called index is because you
want to use that that number or the
variable inside your for loop here so
for example I can do something like this
or I can say print index and you're
going to see that index changes from one
two three four five depending on which
iteration of the loop it is it keeps
track of basically where we're at in
this range right here as we're looping
through it but again what we've
specified here as a counter is only
available inside this scope here in
between these curly brackets I can't
specify you know printing index out here
it's not going to recognize it okay so
we can't do that and furthermore if you
don't need to use index inside your for
loop you can very simply place an
underscore there so this is perfect for
the example that we had initially where
we're just printing hello five times we
don't really need a counter of any sort
where we don't need to refer to index we
don't care which iteration it's
currently at one thing I want to mention
which is confusing often for beginners
is this idea of scope here for example
if I wanted to sum up the numbers from
one to five and I wanted to print out
the result after the for loop let's say
I declare a variable up here and I call
it sum I equate it to zero and then I
say something like sum plus equals and
actually let's add this index variable
back here and I go like this now you
haven't seen this plus equals sign yet
but this operator basically equates to
something like this it takes some and it
adds the index so this is equivalent to
writing this is just kind of like a
short form okay so first of all if
I declare this variable called some
inside my for loop inside these curly
brackets
well this variable is only available
within that scope within these two curly
brackets I can't go out here outside of
the for loop after it's run five times
and print out the result of some see you
can see that it can't find this variable
even though I've declared it in here
okay so why don't we move this print
statement into the for loop what would
you expect to happen in this case well
we get one two three four five again and
why is it that this sum isn't increasing
why isn't it continually adding index to
it and you know why aren't I getting the
sum of the numbers from one to five by
the last iteration of the loop well
what's happening is that in the first
iteration of the loop we're declaring
sum equals to zero and then we're adding
index to sum which is one and then we're
printing sum so that's why we get one
down here in the second iteration of the
loop what we're doing is we're declaring
some again we're setting it to zero and
we are adding this time the index is 2
and we're adding 2 to 0 right and then
it's going to print 2 so that's why you
can see the output 2 right there well
right now you might point out to me hey
Chris I thought you said that you can't
read it clear the same variable you know
in the first iteration the loop we're
declaring var sum right and then in the
second iteration of the loop weari
declaring for some that's that's illegal
that's not allowed in fact you might say
that you know if I declare var string
again up here it's gonna throw an error
all right we can tree declare the same
variable because we've declared this guy
up here we can't read eclair it using
the var again and I would say that's
true except that in each iteration of
the loop it's almost as if it doesn't
remember what happened in the previous
iteration there's no memory or
recollection of the previous iteration
so each iteration is kind of like a
clean slate and it's going to execute
this code right here so just to say that
again you're right if you're saying that
I can't read Eclair some right because
if I try to do that right here
Xcode would throw an error however
inside of a loop in this scope right
here each iteration of the loop is like
a clean slate okay now if I wanted to
actually find out the sum of the numbers
from 1 to 5 what I would actually do is
I would move this declaration up here
outside of the loop and then what I
would do this way I could move this
print statement outside of the loop and
what this for in loop will do is simply
loop from 1 to 5 each time adding index
to the sum and now I'm actually keeping
track of the sum so you can see that
after five iterations of the loop adding
the numbers from 1 to 5 into sum which
started out as 0 the result is 15 down
here and that's from this print
statement okay so I'm going to stop the
lesson there while the syntax for the
for in loop is actually pretty simple
and and the concept of repeating a piece
of code for a certain number of time is
pretty simple I want to give you some
breathing room to digest what we talked
about in regards to the variable scope
so I would recommend that you try
declaring and creating this loop on your
own computer try declaring the variables
inside the loop and outside the loop and
see where you can access them and use
them and where you cannot it's really
going to help and aid you in your
learning hello welcome to learn Swift
for beginners lesson 6 in this video I'd
like to introduce you to two more types
of loops and that is the while loop and
the repeat a while loop in these two
loops let's
you execute some code until some
condition is met so that's different
from the foreign loop where it repeated
a certain number of times okay let's do
it for this lesson
we're going to create a brand new
playground and I'm just going to call
this the loop to play around
okay so let's cover the while loop first
take a look at this slide and let's go
through how to declare a while loop so
the key word here is while followed by
that you have some sort of condition and
it's very similar to an if statement so
the while loop is going to repeat that
chunk of code as long as the condition
is true but as soon as that condition
becomes false it's not going to repeat
the code anymore after your condition
you have a set of curly brackets and
inside of the curly brackets that's
where you have the code that you want to
repeat so let's do a quick example back
in our playground so I'm just going to
declare a variable here I'm going to
call this let's say counter and I am
going to set this counter to ten and
then I would like to print hello I don't
see use five instead so it doesn't print
that many times and I would like to
print hello as long as the counter is
above zero let's say so I would say
something like while counter is greater
than zero I would I would do this print
right here however this is going to keep
repeating as you can see because counter
is always five so inside my while loop
I'm going to computer is dying okay
as you can see it eventually overflows
and crashes okay so what I'm doing here
is I am decrementing counter by one for
each iteration of the loop so as you saw
when I didn't have this line of code it
just kept printing hello many many times
because this condition would always be
would always be false
there was nothing changing the counter
variable from five to zero so I'm just
going to warn you about that if you're
gonna try this on your own computer you
know if you have a slower computer and
might it might take a lot longer for you
to get out of that out of that loop so
you can write this statement first and
make sure you have a statement that is
decrementing your counter so again this
minus equals is the equivalent of
writing something like this counter
equals counter minus one so you're just
taking whatever value counter is your
minus thing one and you're setting that
as a new value for counter as you can
see here it's what you would expect
right you get hello five times now let
me point something out to you right here
what if counter was let's say negative
five you can see here that nothing gets
printed out because this loop is going
to see if this condition is false or
true before executing the code right so
it valuates the condition and then it
decides whether or not it should run
this and repeat it now the second type
of loop the repeat while loop is very
similar to the while loop except that it
checks the condition after looping once
so it checks the condition down here
let's take a look at the syntax so you
start with the keyword repeat and then
you have a set of curly brackets and
inside the set of curly brackets you
place the code you want to loop or
repeat
and then after the ending curly bracket
you have a while keyword and you then
you have the condition so the syntax of
this repeat while loop is very intuitive
actually it's basically saying repeat
this piece of code while this condition
is true okay so let's go back to the
playground and let's do an example here
so I am going to use the same example
ok let's print hello here and we're
gonna have the same thing counter equals
counter minus 1 and we're going to say
repeat this chunk of code while counter
is greater than 0 so as you can see it's
pretty much the same loop or same
condition rather write while counter is
greater than 0 and that's the same thing
I have up here for this while loop and
let's just print something else here so
we can differentiate it and you can see
the repeat while loop actually prints it
out once and then it checks the
condition and it realizes oh I shouldn't
repeat this chunk of code because this
is false right
whereas this while loop it checks the
condition first and it realizes this
condition is not true and it won't print
at all so that's that's the main
difference between the two types of
loops both types of loops will repeat of
chunk of code until a certain condition
is false except that the while loop
checks first and the repeat while loop
checks the condition after repeating
once hello welcome to learn Swift for
beginners lesson 7 in this lesson you're
going to learn what functions how to use
them what they are and this is a
critical part of the Swift programming
language if you want to build apps with
it so let's get started
so here I've got a brand new Xcode
playground where we're going to take a
look at what functions are and how to
use them how to define one how to call
one if you don't know how to start a new
playground just go back to lesson one of
this learn Swift series okay let's start
with what a function is at it's very
core
a function simply allows you to take a
chunk of code give it a function name
and then whenever you call that function
name it's going to execute that chunk of
code now that may seem simple but over
the course of the next couple of videos
you're going to see just how complex and
powerful functions can be functions are
really useful because it allows us to
break down and group our code into
smaller chunks and we can organize them
so that each function or each chunk of
code has a specific task and when you
want to do that specific task then you
just call that function so let's see how
a function is defined in Swift code and
then we'll jump into some examples in
our playground so here we have the
syntax for our basic definition of a
function now it can get more complex
than this because there are a lot more
features of functions that we can use
but we're going to explore those in the
next couple of videos for this example
here is your kind of basic definition of
a function you start with the func
keyword that's f UNC followed by the
function name now this function name is
what you're going to use to call the
function now right after the function
name you have two parentheses or two
rounded brackets in this basic
definition there is nothing in between
these two brackets no spaces nothing in
the next two videos you're going to see
what those brackets are used for but for
now those brackets are just there as
part of the definition there's nothing
in between them and then you're going to
have a set of curly brackets and as you
would expect in between the curly
brackets you would put the code for the
function so whatever you call the
function name that code in between those
curly brackets that code is going to be
executed all right let's jump into the
playground and do some examples
I'm going to declare a function that is
going to add two numbers together and
it's going to print the result to the
console so I'm going to start by using
the funky word to declare a function and
now I have to have a function name so
I'm going to say add two numbers that's
my function name and you'll notice that
I'm using the same camel case as I do
for declaring variables where I start
with a lowercase letter of the first
word and the following words uses a
capital letter then I have my two
rounded brackets like that followed by a
set of curly brackets like that and
sometimes when you type in this first
curly braket or the opening bracket and
then you press Enter Xcode will
automatically add this ending curly
bracket for you okay so in between the
two curly brackets I am going to say let
a equal one let B equals two and I am
going to let's see equals a plus B okay
and then finally we're going to print
the result of C so you can see here that
nothing actually happens because this
function hasn't been called this code is
sitting here if we had written this code
instead of putting it into a function so
let me just delete this for now like
that and this is what we've been doing
so far before we learned about functions
we would just declare these constants
here and then print C and you would see
all of this stuff in the output now I'm
just going to undo those two deletions
so to wrap this code inside of a
function now you can see nothing gets
output until I actually call the
function to execute this code right here
so how do we call a function so in order
to call a function you just have to
write the function name followed by the
two rounded brackets now because we
don't have anything inside these two
rounded broq
that's all we have to do but as you're
going to learn in a couple of videos
later if we have something in between
these brackets the calling the function
would require a little more work but for
this basic function we can invoke that
function simply by writing its name so
add two numbers as you can see here
autocomplete even suggests so all I have
to do is highlight that line press ENTER
and what happens now we get three output
into our console because by calling that
function it just ran the code down here
and I can call this again as many times
as I'd like and anywhere I'd like one
benefit is that if you need to execute a
chunk of code several times this is a
big savings rather than writing this
code out multiple times I just put it
inside a function give it a name and now
I can invoke that piece of code whenever
I call this function name like this so
it helps you reuse code especially if
that chunk of code is going to be used
multiple times in your app you don't
want to write out the same chunk of code
multiple times in and around your app
because it makes it really hard to debug
for example if you've got an issue with
this chunk of code and imagine if you
had it repeated several times in your
app in order to fix it you'd have to fix
it in every single one of those places
but if I have this chunk of code inside
this function I would only have to
troubleshoot and debug this piece of
code once here and as soon as I change
this let's say I change this a to a two
and let's say that fixed my code and you
can see here wherever I call add two
numbers the code is updated so I only
need to update and change the code in
one place whereas if I wrote this chunk
of code out in multiple places in my app
I would have to change it in all of
those places another benefit I mentioned
is that it lets you group this chunk of
code that performs a specific task into
a function that describes what that
chunk of code does so it helps you
organize your code so there is one more
thing I want to mention about functions
and that is about scope so same thing we
learned about inside of loops in terms
of defining variables applies here as
well so let me give you an example of
what I'm saying so let's say I get rid
of those two function calls and we
simply have this function here we have
these three constants C is obviously
four right and inside this function I'm
printing C so outside of my function
let's say I want to print C well that is
actually going to throw an error that
doesn't work why because the constants
and variables that you declare inside a
function can only be used in the
function in between these two curly
brackets and likewise if I declared
another function really quickly so
inside this function I also cannot
access the constants that I declared
here so if I declared constant like that
D equals 1 I can't say you know let e
equals C minus D or something like that
inside this function it's not going to
recognize what C is right here so let's
get rid of this first okay so there you
can see the error it doesn't know what C
is because C is defined inside add two
numbers and so it only recognizes C
within this scope a B and C in fact so
inside here inside this function I'm
free to declare a again because it only
applies within these brackets like that
so I can have a minus D and let's end
off by printing e okay so the main
takeaways for this lesson right here
you've learned about what functions are
and why they're beneficial you've
learned how to define a simple function
you've learned how to call that function
so you can execute the code inside of
that function and furthermore you
learned about the scope inside of a
function
and just to remind you about that it's
that whatever you declare inside of the
curly brackets of a function is only
recognized and can be used inside of
those curly brackets in the next video
we're going to build upon what we learn
here in this lesson and you're going to
learn how to make functions even more
powerful so thanks for watching if you
liked the video please give it a thumbs
up it helps this video get seen by more
people and subscribe for more hello
welcome to learn Swift for beginners
lesson eight in the previous lesson you
learned about functions how to declare
them and how to call them in this lesson
you're going to learn how to use them in
a even more powerful way by having your
functions accept data and also return
data to you when you call them alright
let's see how that's done so here I have
a fresh playground if you forget how to
open up a new playground just go back to
lesson 1 of this series and you can see
how now there's one thing I want to
mention before we move on that I forgot
to mention in the previous video and
that is that sometimes I may
accidentally say method and when I say
method I actually mean function now I
noticed that a lot of other Swift
teachers also do this and the reason for
this is because for many Swift educators
like myself Swift isn't our first
programming language and in many of the
programming languages out there there is
some concept of a function and sometimes
they're called functions sometimes
they're called methods and sometimes
even other things so a lot of the
educators out there when they're
teaching sometimes they're going to slip
up and they're gonna say method instead
so I just want to put it out there if
you hear me say method just know that
sometimes I use function and Method
interchangeably okay so we're going to
start by just read eclair enough unction
to previous lesson and I want to read
eclair it just for extra practice for
you guys so I think it was something
like add two numbers like this and it
was let a equals one
let be equals one and let's see equals a
plus B and then we're going to print C
just like that now in the previous
lesson I mentioned that functions are
great for kind of organizing your little
bits of code into pieces of code that
perform one task so in this case this
function would add the two numbers
together and then it would print out
that sum in the console but what if I
wanted the function to just add the two
numbers but don't print it out I just
want the result
so in fact functions have something
called a return value and it's exactly
how it sounds when you execute the
function it returns a value to you so
let's take a look at what the syntax is
for specifying that a function returns a
value so everything remains the same as
our basic function definition but after
the two rounded brackets you have an
arrow that arrow is just comprised of a
- and a greater than sign and followed
by that you have the data type of the
value that this function should return
so now that you specified that this
function returns value you have to use
the return keyword inside of that
function to actually return a value of
that same data type that you specified
so now let's go back to our playground
and see how this applies to the function
that we have there so let's say that for
this function I don't want to print out
the sum instead I wanted to return the
sum to me I would then erase this print
statement first of all after the rounded
brackets I would put - greater than sign
and then I would put int specifying that
this function should return an int data
type
now Xcode immediately throws an error
here because it notices that I don't
have the return keyword I'm not
returning an integer value like I said I
would so what I would have to do
actually to fix this is used the return
keyword and I'm going to return C
because that's the sum of a and B
so now when I call add two numbers like
that it actually returns see now let me
show you something here so when I type
that autocomplete it shows you the
return value right there it tells me
that add two numbers actually returns an
integer like that so what I would do
essentially is I would probably declare
a constant and let's call it sum and I
would say equals add two numbers what's
happening here is that I'm calling this
function add two numbers and this
function is returning C as in the sum of
one plus one and I'm assigning that
value into this constant called sum so
now if I print sum like that I would get
two so this constant sum it stores the
returned value from my function here so
one more thing I can do up here instead
of declaring this constant C equals a
plus B and then returning C I could
actually get rid of this constant and I
could just return a plus B like that and
that would actually take a and B add
them together and then return it so
that's return values for functions and
this is really powerful because now you
can write a function that does something
and returns the result to you so your
function is kind of like a little worker
or a piece of code that does a specific
task and then returns you back the
result now there's another cool thing
that you can do with functions and
that's called parameters C this function
by itself add two numbers it's always
just going to add one and one together
and return to to me but what if I wanted
this piece of code to be reusable for
any type of numbers I want to specify
which two numbers I want to add together
so essentially what it is is when I
declare this function I can specify in
between these two rounded brackets see I
mentioned in the previous video that we
would
use this in between these two rounded
brackets we can specify that this
function needs some input parameters in
order to execute so let's say that I'm
going to declare this function and say
that when you call this function you
need to give me two numbers as inputs
now when I call the function here I
would have to specify two numbers in
between these rounded brackets okay so
before we actually do it let's go take a
look at what the syntax looks like for
declaring these input parameters so this
syntax right here shows you what the
function definition would look like for
a single parameter now we're going to
get to multiple parameters but this is
an example of a single parameter
function declaration so in between the
two rounded brackets you have an
argument label okay and I'll explain to
you in a second what that is and then
you have a parameter name followed by a
colon and then followed by the data type
of the parameter you're accepting now
let's talk about the parameter name :
data type part first
so obviously the colon data type part of
that specifies what sort of parameter
you're going to be passing into the
function and the parameter name is going
to be the name of that parameter you use
within the function so if I wanted to
take that input and I wanted to add it
to something and I wanted to reference
that value that was passed in I would
use the parameter name okay inside the
function
now the argument label for that
parameter is what is going to be shown
when you call that function I know it's
a little bit confusing right now but
let's jump into an example so it makes
more sense all right so back to the
playground here let's implement one
parameter inside our add two numbers
function here so I'm not going to use
any descriptive names right now because
I want to show you how the argument
label and the parameter name plays out
so I'm going to say add two numbers are
label is let's just say argh and then
the parameter I'm just going to say para
okay and then : int so this function now
accepts a parameter that is type of int
and then Xcode detects that now this
function call is incorrect because we
have no function that doesn't accept the
parameters so one cool thing you can do
is just erase that and go add two
numbers you can see that autocomplete
now recognizes that we have a parameter
so let's double click that and you can
see here is the argument label let's
pass it in a number here let's pass in
let's pass in two like that so by
specifying arg
there as the argument label for the
parameter when I call the function I'm
going to have this label here if I
wanted to use this number that I passed
in remember you have to use the
parameter name that's four inside the
function so I would reference the value
that's passed in using the parameter
name like that so essentially what I
would get here is because I'm passing in
two and I'm referencing I'm setting a as
two right that's our parameter that just
got passed in it would be two plus one
so that's what is stored into some and
when I'm printing some that's what I
expect to get three okay that is helpful
but it's not complete we want to be able
to pass in both numbers so that we can
specify which two numbers to add
together let's take a look at the syntax
for multiple parameters so the syntax
for multiple parameters is very easy in
the parameter list that is that stuff
between the rounded brackets you would
just put a comma after the first
parameter and then essentially repeat
the same thing for the second parameter
you'd have an argument label followed by
space followed by a parameter name colon
and then the data type now you want to
use different or
labels and different parameter names
obviously so that you'd be able to tell
it apart now let's jump back to the
playground and add our second parameter
so what I would do in between these
rounded brackets in this parameter list
is I would just put comma and then I
would put my second argument label my
second parameter name followed by the
data type which is another int now again
Xcode is going to throw this error here
let's use autocomplete again add two
numbers you can see here it's been
updated to accept two arguments
so argument just Arg and Arg - so let's
pass in two and two now we have to
modify our code a bit right now I'm
still getting three and that's because
inside this function code I'm not using
the parameter two yet we can change that
like that so now a gets set to parameter
I mean para and B get set to para two
and then I'm returning a plus B so now I
actually get four in here so one thing
we can do with this function is actually
we don't need to declare a equals para
and B equals para 2 that doesn't really
do anything so we can get rid of these
two constants here and we can simply
return para
plus para 2 like that straight off the
bat now our function is pretty simple so
at this point you might be wondering why
is it so confusing that I'm using
argument labels here in the function
call and then we're using parameter
names inside the function code well what
you can do is you can actually not
specify argument labels like that and
just have the parameter names and what
it'll do is it's going to use the
parameter name both as the argument
label and the parameter name so now this
is wrong you can see xcode here has an
error let's use autocomplete to see what
the new function looks like the new
function call and you can see here that
now the argument labels are the
their names so we can also change our
parameter names at this point you
probably don't want to use pair around
para to for your own function so we can
say you know number one number two if we
have these us our parameter names then
you know this changes as well number one
number two and then our function call
would also change like that okay now you
might be wondering why why use argument
labels at all like what are they for
well with using argument labels you can
make your function calls a little more
like natural English so let me show you
an example you can do something like
this
add two numbers so there's my first
argument label and number two like that
so let's take a look at what our new
function call would look like so when
I'm calling a function add two numbers
using two and two all right you can see
how that reads more like natural English
and it makes intuitive sense what the
parameters are going to be used for
meanwhile inside our our function here
if my parameter names were using right
or and it doesn't make much sense right
you know if I didn't use if I used these
as the parameter names like that these
would be terrible parameter names
because if my function is really long
this doesn't tell me anything this
doesn't tell me anything doesn't mean
anything to me while this function call
still makes a lot of sense when you call
it in terms of natural English but in in
the actual code in here and add two
numbers you know adding using it and n
doesn't really make sense so if you use
the combination of
argument labels and parameter names that
make sense you have this function call
that is like natural English and makes
sense and you also have meaningful
parameter names that you can use inside
of your function okay so I want to show
you one more thing if you don't want to
use these argument labels at all what
you can do is replace your argument
labels with an underscore like that or
you can replace one or you can replace
both so let me show you what that looks
like so I'm gonna replace both the
argument labels with just underscore
let's take a look at what that looks
like now so you can see now that I just
pass in two and two like that no
parameter names no labels no arguments
no nothing it's just you pass in the
input parameters like this and you these
are your parameter names so that's what
you're going to be using inside of your
function okay so just to recap in this
lesson you learned about return values
you learned about the return keyword and
you learn about input parameters and how
to specify them what argument labels are
what parameter names are and also how to
omit argument labels all together I hope
you enjoyed this lesson if you did
please give the video a thumbs up and
please subscribe for more hello welcome
to learn Swift for beginners lesson 9 in
this video you're going to be introduced
to classes which is an absolutely
critical part of the Swift programming
language if you're going to be using it
to build apps I'll tell you all about it
let's get started
so I'm gonna start off with a
hypothetical example so let's say you
have something like a blog post which
you would like to represent we might
have something like a variable here for
blog title all right blog title can be
hello playground I don't know what kind
of article that would be but we would
have another variable for the blog body
and this is the you know text of the
article or the blog post and then we
might have something like blog author
which in this case let's just put my
name here so you can see here this is
the data for one blog post now let's say
I had two blog posts what what would I
do in this case I might have another set
of variables down here and of course I
can't have the same variable names so
let's just append two to these these
variable names and let's say this is I
don't know this article is good by
playground okay now this is what I have
for two blog articles now what if I had
ten what if I had a hundred how many
variables would I have then it it'd be a
ton right it would be a mess there needs
to be a better way to represent a blog
post to kind of group these variables
together and there is in fact that's
what a class is you know how you learned
about the different data types back in
lesson two you learned about the string
data type you learned about the int data
type float double boolean all of those
are data types to represent different
types of data right well with classes
you can define your own custom data type
so what we're going to do here is we're
going to create our custom data type
called blog post for example you can do
that with classes let's take a look at
the syntax for declaring a new class so
first of all you have the class keyword
next you have the name of the class
and this is going to be the name of your
datatype then you follow by two curly
brackets and inside those two curly
brackets is your class definition let's
take a look at this back in our
playground so for example up here let's
create and define our class so first I
would use the class keyword and then I
would create a name of the datatype or
the name of the class in this case let's
put blog post and notice that this time
I'm starting off with a capital letter
in fact all of the data types in Swift
start off with the capital letter so we
should follow the same convention I
always start off your class names with
the capital letter and that's different
from what we've been doing with
variables and constants and functions
okay then I have these two curly
brackets like that what do I put inside
of my blog post class well why don't we
put this stuff right here I'm just going
to cut it and I'm going to paste it
inside here and then I'm gonna delete
this right here and I am going to delete
this text inside these variables inside
my class and leave them empty and I'm
going to explain why in a second okay so
just like that we've defined a class
called blog post and this class has
three properties now a property is just
a variable declaration like this but
inside a class it's called a property
and you're gonna see why in a second why
it makes more sense and because this
blog title blog body blog author is
inside of blog post it's kind of
redundant to name them like this so I'm
just going to name them title body and
author like that okay so this this
represents our blog
right here now that you've defined what
a blog post is let's create an actual
blog post because remember this class
definition right here this is just a
definition of a data type you're
defining what a blog post data type is
right so that's not an actual blog post
just like how this is a string that's
not the definition of a string that's an
actual string so in order to create an
actual blog post we're going to type in
the class name followed by two rounded
brackets like that and just like that
this is a new instance of the blog post
type and it's called an object or blog
post object so when you define a new
class using the class keyword that's
what's known as a class definition or
just class but when you create actual
instances of that class those are called
objects you can think of your class
definition as a template or a blueprint
and you use that template to create
actual tangible blog post objects so
let's jump back to the playground here
this is a very important concept to
understand we've defined a class called
blog post here it's got these three
properties or you can think of them as
attributes of a blog post and then down
here like this we've created a new blog
post object now this blog post object
has a title it has a body and has an
author but all of it all of them are
empty right now so what we're going to
do is we're going to assign this blog
post object into a constant let's call
it my post like that so what we've done
here is we've created a new blog post
objects we've assigned it to my post and
now why don't we try setting the title
of this blog post and the body and the
author what we would do is say my post
right that's referring to this new
object and then we press dot and that
lets us access those properties which
we've defined in the class definition
I set the title to I don't know hello
playground I think that's what we had
before let's set the author of this one
and let's set the body to hello
okay just hello now if I print my post
dot author I would get my name now let
me show you something else we can create
a second instance of blog post or a
second blog post object and let's call
this my second post and we're going to
set this to a new blog post object like
that
and we're gonna say my second post title
equals goodbye playground and we can set
the author to someone else let's say
John Travolta I don't know why that
suddenly popped into my head and let's
just do hello again now this is a second
my post object this is different from my
post these are completely two different
blog post objects both of them contain
these three properties which we can set
because that's what we've defined here
in this class now another very cool
thing about classes is that you can put
functions in them all right you can see
how all of the lessons so far are coming
together let's create a new property for
this first let's say a number of
comments equals 0 this is the number of
comments in the blog post and we're
going to define a new function in this
blog post class we're gonna say add
comment okay and we're not going to
worry about the comment text just yet
let's just define this so notice that in
my function definition
I have these two curly brackets again
inside here this is gonna be my function
code so inside this function I am just
going to increase the number of comments
by one this is all stuff that you should
have learned already in the previous
lessons now okay so now every single
blog post object is going to have this
function now how do we access it we
simply go my post dot you can see now in
the autocomplete that there is this
function called add comment and it
doesn't have any return value it doesn't
return anything so the return type is
void right there let's call this
function okay see what happens so add
comment you can't visibly see what
happens but let's print my post dot
number of comments you can see that it's
one okay now let's print my second post
dot number of comments what would you
expect this to print out it prints out
zero why because we haven't called the
add comment function on my second post
we just did that with the first post
each of these blog post objects
maintains its own properties changing
the properties of one object does not
affect the other even though they're cut
from the same cloth
right there both types of blog posts
there are two independent entities and
they maintain their properties
separately now there's a lot more to
classes but fundamentally I want you to
understand what they are so I'm not
going to make this video any longer than
it needs to be I just wanted to
introduce classes to you I hope you can
see why classes are a fundamental
building block to organize your
information so thanks for watching
please give this video a thumbs up if it
helped you and please subscribe for more
hello welcome to learn Swift for
beginners lesson 10 in this video you're
going to learn about inherit
otherwise known as sub classing which
allows us to build upon previous classes
which we've already defined and it saves
us a lot of time and effort and work so
that we don't have to keep defining
classes that do similar things okay so
let's get started and see how this works
let me start by doing a small recap of
what you've learned in this series so
far so you learn about variables and
constants to store and keep track of
data you also learned about some control
flow and conditional statements so that
you can express logic and make decisions
with your code and then you learn about
functions where you can define blocks of
code that perform specific tasks as a
way of organizing your code into more
manageable chunks and then you learn
about classes which is a further way
where you can organize related code and
related functions together as well as
related variables in the form of
properties and then today you're going
to learn about inheritance
aka sub-classing as a way to further
organize your code okay so let's take a
look at inheritance in a playground so
I'm going to launch Xcode here I'm going
to get started with a brand new
playground and let's call this in here
tunes playground okay let's just save it
on my desktop there and get rid of this
line of code so let's say that the app
we're building is kind of like a car
simulator or something like that and we
need to define a class that represents a
car so we're going to start by creating
a car class just like that and some of
the things that it may have is for
example it needs to keep track of a top
speed right because different cars may
have different ranges for the top speed
I'm just going to initialize that to 200
so there may be a whole ton of other
attributes or properties to do with cars
but for demo purposes I only need one so
I'm not going to go further than
defining top speed there and I wanted to
find a function so
car by definition is a vehicle that can
be driven right so I'm going to create a
function called drive just like that it
doesn't accept any parameters and inside
this function it's going to perform all
the code that we need to drive a car but
you know for this demo I'm just going to
print driving at and then I'm going to
put in top speed like that
so this this value in this top speed
property gets substituted in there and
then it prints out driving at whatever
this value is 200 so what I call the
drive function it's going to print this
statement out into the console okay so
we've defined our class here that
represents a car and in the previous
lessons you've learned about how to
create a new object right from the car
class so why don't we declare a constant
called my ride and we're going to create
a new car object and assign it into the
constant my ride just like that we've
created a new car object now let me try
accessing top speed where you press dot
and then you can access the property
there as you can see it's running the
playground okay you can see 200 there
and let's try calling the function my
ride dot drive that and you can see it
says driving at 100 okay so now let's
say that in this driving simulator app I
also have something called a super car
or maybe a future car so it's the car of
the future
for example and it can fly so it's the
flying car that it will probably come in
the future so we can define another
class to represent that and we can call
it future car right
and again this future car because it is
a car still it's gonna have a top speed
and let's say this top speed is 250 like
that and it's also got a
function called drive and because you
can still drive this car and again it's
just going to print you know driving at
top speed and also this car can fly so
let me define another function that
represents you know flying the car so
flying I'm just gonna call it flying
like that so here we've defined our car
class we have to find a future car right
here if I want to create another let's
call it my new ride this is a constant
and this time I'm going to create a new
future car object like that and then my
new ride you can see has fly now right
and has Drive and it has top speed now
let me ask you this question see we you
can see the similarities between car and
future car right they both have the
properties of a basic car like a top
speed and they both have this drive
function which is very very similar in
fact it's actually identical so this is
pretty redundant right there's a lot of
redundancy between these two class
definitions so this is where inheritance
or subclassing comes into play and it's
very helpful so what inheritance allows
us to do is say that one class inherits
from another class and essentially what
that means is that if future car
inherits from car it's going to inherit
its properties and functions so you
don't need to redefine them inside
future car so let me show you what I
mean here let's in future car let's
delete this top speed property and let's
delete this drive function and what I'm
going to do instead is I'm going to make
future car inherit from car and the way
you do that is after the class and then
class name you put : like that and then
you put the class that it inherits from
so in this case I would
but car so in this sort of relationship
we have car at the top and we have
future car at the bottom inheriting all
of the properties and the functions from
the car class in this case future car
would be called a subclass of car and
car would be called the superclass of
future car and some people might call it
the parent class so car is the
superclass or the parent class or maybe
simply the parent of future car let's go
back to our playground and take a look
at what this means for our code here so
you can see that my ride is still a car
object and it still has top speed and it
still has Drive but take a look at my
new ride right it's a future car object
and remember inside future car we've
just defined a fly we haven't defined
anything else in here but if I type in
my new ride and I press dot here and let
autocomplete do its thing you can see
that future car actually has a drive
function and actually has a top speed so
you know if I do top speed you can see
it's 200 and if I do drive you can see
that now future car or my new ride
rather is also driving at 200 and
furthermore actually my new ride can
also fly okay so there's flying now
there's actually a problem here because
right now my car and my future car
they're both driving at the same speed
but remember the future cars are faster
right or initially I wrote the top speed
was 250 so in this case what we can do
is to do something called overriding and
that allows you to take a function or a
property from the parent class or the
superclass and redefine it to
essentially that's where the word
override comes from so you're overriding
the parents version of that function and
you're providing your own implementation
or your own version of it let me just do
it here so you can see what it means
so we use the override keyword like that
and then we have to declare drive
exactly as it is in the parent class so
what we're doing is we're going to say
print driving at and we're going to
instead say top speed plus 50 because
this guy goes faster so now you can see
that when I call this guy what I call
future car drive it doesn't use the
parent classes drive function it uses
its own overridden definition of what
drive is and so that this is the code
that it's running here and you can see
it's driving at 250 okay so that's an
example of overriding to provide your
own custom functionality now inside this
overridden method there is a way that we
can access still the parent
functionality and you can do that by
using the keyword super so let me show
you what I mean inside this over it in
Drive function I can actually access the
parent class the definition all the
functions and properties in there if I
type in super dot and then I can access
drive so when I do this super refers to
the parent class or the super class and
this drive function is actually calling
this guy up here all right so in this
case it doesn't make sense you can see
in the console when I type in future
card drive it you know it calls the
original definition of drive and then it
prints this you know its own definition
of drive so you know in this example it
doesn't really make sense but sometimes
when you're building your apps what you
want to do is add functionality and not
override the functionality if that makes
sense
so you don't want to replace what's in
the parent class you just want to add to
it
and so you can do that if you you know
you can call the original definition and
then you can add your own code before or
after
that to provide additional functionality
so in this case maybe I'll just change
the statement here and rockets boosting
at you know 50 or something like that so
let's see so now you can see that this
is my original car right when I call
drive it says driving at 200 and then my
future car is driving at 200 and it's
doing something extra and so that's
that's how this overridden function
works okay so this is a simplified
example of how subclassing works but
it's essentially how it works and it's
very predominant in the Swift
programming language as I'm going to
show you in the next lesson as you can
see inheritance allows you to save a lot
of work by taking what's already there
and then improving it or providing you
know alternate definitions so you don't
have to redefine everything all over
again but you can build upon the classes
that you already have okay thanks for
watching please help me continue to
create more videos for you by giving
this video a thumbs up and subscribing
to the channel hello welcome to lesson
11 of the learn Swift for beginners
series in this lesson I want to
introduce to you UIKit it's an apple
framework that contains many of the
classes we're going to need in order to
construct iOS apps all right so let's
dive in and see what's available in UI
kit
so like I mentioned in the intro for
this video the uikit framework is
essentially a library of classes that
Apple gives us to build apps with when
you think about it there are a lot of
common elements to any sort of app for
example apps may have views they may
have buttons you know all apps are going
to have things that you need to present
to the user apps are going to need to
handle user interaction from the person
using the app and so on and so forth so
to build that functionality out every
single time you're going to build an app
is extremely tedious and not to mention
complex and complicated so Apple has
provided UI kit for us to use and it
contains a ton of pre-built classes for
us to handle all of these common things
so here I'm looking at the UI kit
reference guide which contains a list of
all of the UI kit classes that are
available for us to use I'll link to it
in the description below the video but
if you want to look for it yourself just
go into google and type in Apple space
UI kit don't just type in UI kit because
the first few results for that query
isn't the Apple UI kit so just type in
Apple space UI kit to find the correct
one in the first result it was also
essential to learn about inheritance
before I told you about UI kit because
many of these classes inherit from each
other they build off of each other so
they don't redefined things and this
reference guide used to be kind of
organized in a hierarchy so you could
see which classes inherited from other
classes but since they've changed it and
they've made it kind of a listing so you
don't get that but I did a google search
and I found an image that I'm sure this
is not the complete UI kit because this
image was from 2012 I think yeah you can
see here in the URL it's from 2012 but
it does give you an idea of how the
classes are organized so you can see at
the very top of this tree if you can
imagine
this left side being kind of at the top
of the tree and this right side being
the bottom of it if you take for an
instance this uibutton class which
represents a button that the user can
tap on the screen UI button inherits
from UI control which inherits from
uiviewcontroller or granddaddy and what
this nsobject class does is it provides
that basic functionality that allows you
to create an object from a class
definition so that's something we went
through in part one of the classes
lesson so this NS object class and it
gives you that functionality and if we
take a look at what was the next one
down the chain so the UI responder class
so this UI responder class inherits from
nsobject means that it contains that
foundation that's going to be needed by
you know all of these UI elements or
user interface elements okay so the next
one down is a UI view so UI view
inherits from UI responder which
inherits from nsobject so UI view gets
all of that functionality and on top of
that the UI view class provides
functionality for displaying something
onto a view so a UI view is something
that you can show to the user so it
contains all of that functionality and
code and then next in that hierarchy
down to the UI button we have UI control
now you like control contains all of
that functionality before it following
this line here and on top of that
contains basic code and functionality
for a user element control so stuff that
is specific for displaying on to a view
handling user in
action and events and responding so then
we have a specific type of UI control
and that is the UI button which is
pretty self-explanatory it looks and
behaves like a button with certain
button events so that's just one example
of you know the path you can see that
there's a whole ton of classes and
there's even more now so whenever you go
and you know before you go and do
something with your app chances are you
can probably leverage something from UI
kit to build off of rather than building
something from scratch so in this video
I just wanted to give you guys an
introduction to UI kit because we're
going to be using a lot of classes from
here and every time I do I will try and
remember to reference this guide or at
least link to it so you can take a look
at these classes it's very useful and
handy to have at your fingertips because
you can click into these classes and
then you can find out for this UI button
class what sorts of functions it has and
properties it has that you can use and
leverage and how you can perform
specific things with the button or with
that class and furthermore I might do
another video series where we go over
specifically different UI elements
because I think that would be useful for
beginners to understand how to use for
example like a date picker or a text
field or a slider or switch or something
like that
so that might be a separate series
aren't just UI elements please give this
video a thumbs up and subscribe to my
channel to help the channel grow hello
welcome to learn Swift for beginners
lesson 12 in this video we're going to
talk about initializer functions for
classes these guys exist to make sure
that when you create a new object from
your class that that object is ready to
be used
plus you can customize these initializer
functions to set up the object any way
you want when you create a new instance
of the class let's get started and see
what that means
[Music]
so what I've got here is a playground
and I wrote down a basic class here
called person and this person class has
got two properties right now it's got a
name property which I've initialized to
an empty string and also it's got an H
property which I've set to zero and that
is an integer now you learned about
classes in a couple of lessons back and
you learned about how we create objects
from classes right and in order to
create a new person object I would say
something like var let's just use the
variable a equals person like that and
we open up and close brackets beside the
class name like that and here I've got a
brand new person object and if I go a
non name you can see that it's an empty
string and if I go a dot age you can see
that it's zero so what's actually
happening when you create a new person
object here and you write these brackets
don't these two brackets look like
you're calling a function but actually
what's happening is you're calling the
initializer function of the person class
but you might ask we don't have one
defined in here what initializer
function are you talking about let me
write it out by default it exists and if
you don't customize it you don't really
have to touch it but that initialization
function looks like this it just uses
the keyword in it and it has these two
brackets and then in here in between
this just like a function you can define
code in here this set up your object so
what's happening when you create a new
person object with this line of code
here is you're actually calling this
init function of the person class and
inside here you can actually write code
to customize things so for example I can
say name equals Chris and H equals I
believe I'm 33 I think I've lost track
so what's gonna happen here when I
create a brand new person object is it's
going to call this a knit function and
it's gonna set these two properties to
these two values here so as you can see
now name is Chris and age is 33 when I
create a brand new person object now
remember how I said that you can
actually customize the anit function to
set up the object the way you want it to
be set up and we can do that simply by
adding some parameters into this init
function just like we would for any
function that we set up so for example I
can say I can say n is a string and a is
an in so now I have to pass in these two
values so let me just erase this part
here and I'm going to create a new
person object and now you can see that
the autocomplete shows me this so for
name I pass in Chris and for the int
I'll pass in 33 but instead of sending
this stuff to the hard-coded values now
I can set up to what is being passed in
here so that's N and that's a alright
when I'm creating a new person object
here I'm passing in these values that go
in through this init function and then
it sets the properties to those values
which I pass in now remember if I don't
want these parameter labels all I need
to do is go like that and you we learn
this through the functions lesson so you
can review that if you forget why this
is these are the argument labels by
putting underscore there we're basically
saying we don't need the argument labels
now while we're on this topic of
specifying these parameters here
oftentimes and sometimes I catch myself
doing this too is that when we're
passing in these parameters the name and
age and you're intending to set it to
these properties here there's a tendency
to name these parameters exactly like
the property names because after all you
name these property names to be
descriptive right of what they represent
so in the parameters you might be
tempted also to name them the same thing
well what happens is you get into this
situation where you're trying to set
this parameter into this property name
but they're both named the same thing so
it's a little bit ambiguous so that's
where you can use this keyword called
self and what how you would use it is
you would say self dot name equals name
so self refers to the object that is
being created so you're saying to set
the name property of the object to this
name parameter so that's how you
distinguish between if the property name
and the parameter name is the same so I
would do the same thing here like that
so then this age refers to that guy and
self dot age refers to the actual
property there now another thing I want
to point out is that I can no longer
call person like that because there's no
init method like that what I can do is I
can actually have multiple initializer
methods so if I do this let's let's say
this is VAR b equals this person object
well this b dot name is empty and b dot
H is 0 right because these guys haven't
been set after all I'm calling this
initializer function here that doesn't
set anything whereas this guy this
initializer function actually sets the
name and age to whatever we pass in now
there's one very important thing we
haven't talked about yet regarding init
functions I mentioned in the intro to
this video that the inant functions are
there to make sure that the object is
properly initialized and all of its
values are set making the object ready
to be used so in this case right here
for the person class I've declared two
properties and I've already preset them
or initialize them to these values here
so really the net function has nothing
to do even if I did nothing as is in
this case right here the object would be
ready to use because these properties
have values in the next lesson I'll show
you how you can sometimes if you need to
declare these properties without setting
or initializing them to values so it
would be something like this you one
write it out like this but just as an
example you wouldn't set it to anything
so there would be no values in here in
that case when you create a new person
object the anit function would be
responsible for making sure that these
guys do have a value because if not all
of these properties are initialized to
values then the object is not considered
to be ready to be used
so the anit function is there to make
sure that the values are set and like I
said so far you haven't learned about
how to declare these properties right
here without sending them the values
I've always have set them to something
but in the next lesson you'll learn how
to do that and then we'll dive a little
deeper into initializer functions and
talk about how there are two types
called designated and convenience
initializers and so on and so forth okay
so thanks for watching remember to give
the video a thumbs up and subscribe to
the channel if you haven't already hello
welcome to lesson 13 of the learn Swift
for beginners series in this video
you're going to learn about optionals
and it's probably one of the most
confusing things for beginners if you've
ever looked at Swift code and you've
noticed exclamation marks or question
marks in the code then you've come
across optionals so let's get started
and find out what it's all about
so right here I have a playground and I
have declared a class blog post in fact
if you've seen episode 9 the first
lesson on classes then this is going to
look familiar because this is the
example that we used for lesson 9 and
when I first talked to you about classes
now we declared a couple of properties
up here for our blog post class and
these properties they represent certain
things about what a blog post might have
so for example the title the body the
author number of comments and you can
actually safely ignore this function so
I'm just going to remove it because
we're going to focus on this stuff up
here you'll notice that each time I
declare a property right here I
immediately initialize it to a value so
title body author are all initialized to
an empty string right when they're
declared and comments is set to zero
right right when it's declared now this
is all fine and dandy but what if you
actually want some of these properties
to be empty for example what if I want
to tell if the blog post has an author
or it doesn't have any author you might
argue that well I can just check if
author is equal to an empty string and
if it's equal to an empty string then
maybe there's no author well what if the
author isn't actually a string what if
it's actually you know we have another
class here and we call it person and
let's say that there's a name and we'll
initialize the empty string but you know
okay so in this case person is assigned
to author so you know blog post has an
has an author because it has this person
object so how do we distinguish there
being no author for a blog post well you
have to be able to declare an author
property and leave it empty because some
blog posts may not have an author so the
way to do this is if you remember from
way way back then maybe
lesson lesson 2 on data types I think
you can actually specify for your
variables the specific data type that it
can store if you don't specify it
basically the data type is inferred from
what you assign into it okay so for
example if I wanted the title to be able
to be empty I would have to declare the
type I'd get rid of this equals empty
string because we don't want to sign in
anything to it right we wanted to clear
this property but leave it empty I would
do it like that
I would you know did : specify the
specific type and then I would put
question mark and that is an optional
right there so when I declare this title
is empty and this part basically tells
us that the data type of title is string
and this question mark attached to the
string data type tells us that it could
be nil which means nothing or empty it
could be nil or it could actually
contain a string so contrast this with
the body property here this when it is
declared is assigned this MD string so
it's always going to have a value right
whether it's empty string or maybe in
the future we assign some text into it
it's gonna have some text but you know
this title property could be empty in
fact it is empty right now as we declare
it so going back to this example with
the author potentially some blog posts
may not have an author so we can't just
you know initialize the author property
to a person object because that would
mean all blog posts at least have a
person attached to the author right we
want to make this property able to be
empty all right so the way we do that
again is we specify the specific data
type put the question mark there next to
the data type and we get rid of that
part because we don't actually want to
assign anything to it okay so in this
way we have a blog post class
which has an optional title property has
a body which is initialized to an empty
string so it at least always has a value
and it may or may not have a person you
know it could have nobody assigned as
the author or can actually have a person
object assigned as the author and number
of comments will always have a value and
starting at zero so you're going to want
to pay attention now because I'm going
to tell you how you should think of
these optional properties that we have
here and this is sort of metaphor or a
visual that you can think of that I was
taught when I was learning this stuff
and that is to think of the title
property this optional string it could
optionally contain a value or not think
of it like a box it's labeled string but
you can't see what's inside the box you
don't know if there's actually a string
object inside or it could just be an
empty box
it could be an empty gift box if someone
if you've been really bad and someone
gives you an empty gift for Christmas
that's never happened to me but if it
has to you let me know in the comment
section below
but anyways you can think of an optional
property like a box that may contain the
actual object or it may not so how can
you find out if there's actually the
string object inside or not well you
have to unwrap that box right you have
to unwrap that gift in order to look
inside and see and get at the the actual
object and that's exactly what we have
to do in code now with our optional
properties so let me let me create a new
blog post object here let me say post
equals blog post like that and what
we're going to do here is we're going to
say hey print out post dot the body plus
I don't know plus hello something like
that okay so it basically just prints
out hello because body is empty but
let's just assign it to something like
that so then we have something like hey
hello right that totally makes sense
because body we've initialized it to hey
right when we create the blog post
object it's already set to hey and then
we concatenate hello to it and so when
we print post body plus hello you know
you're accessing that property and in
your pending hello anyways that makes
sense so we can no longer do that with
something like the title right because
that's an optional it's it's wrapped up
in a gift box and you don't know if it's
empty inside or if there's actually a
string object inside so you can't
blindly use it you have to unwrap that
gift box and and check if there's a
value or not and then use it so now
before we use title we have to check if
there's actually a string object or if
there's actually a value inside that
optional and the way we do that is we do
something called optional binding okay
so it's kind of like an if statement so
you say if but then you use the word let
and if you remember using the keyword
lettuce declaring a constant right in
fact that's exactly what this is you're
declaring a constant here if let actual
title equals title and then you open up
these curly brackets so what you're
doing here is you're testing sorry not
title
I meant host dot title because this is
the optional property here what you're
doing here is you're saying that you're
testing you're unwrapping this this
title property this optional and you're
saying if there is a value in there then
assign it to this constant called actual
title and then inside here you can use
actual title as the value but if there
is nothing inside this optional and if
you unwrap it and it's empty it's nil
then don't execute this code inside
so that's why it has an if statement
here you're basically testing to see if
there's a value inside this optional if
there is you assign it to this constant
and then you use this constant inside
here if there isn't then it's just going
to skip over this whole if statement so
in here we can safely now we can say you
know print actual title plus you know
solute so there is no value in title so
it actually skips all this but let let's
say for instance we say here post title
equals yo like that so now you can see
when it does this optional binding and
it unwraps this title because we have
assigned something into it here it finds
that hey I unwrapped the optional there
is a value I'm gonna assign it to actual
title so inside this if statement we can
use actual title and do this but if I
didn't have this line here let's comment
this out you can see that it it
completely skips this and it doesn't
crash or do anything like that because
we're safely you know checking if
there's a value inside the optional
first and then we're using it now
there's always different ways of doing
things so in the Swift programming
language there's actually a way to UM be
a cowboy and skip all this if you don't
want to check it and you just want to
use the value you know you know there's
something inside what you can do is you
can use you know you're gonna not check
it you're just going to use it you can
movie that the post thought title and
you put this exclamation mark and this
is called force unwrapping so what
you're telling Xcode is you're saying
that hey you know I know there's a value
in here I don't need to check it
I just want to unwrap it right away
using this exclamation mark and I
use whatever is inside of there right in
this case it's yo so here we're you know
we're accessing post title it's an
optional property we don't care we're
gonna force unwrap that and we're gonna
take out that value and use it you know
and so if you know there is a value
inside you can do that but it gets a
little dangerous because for example if
there happens to not be a value in there
and you're forcing wrapping it and
you're trying to you know use the value
well there's an error because and this
is the error you get fatal error
unexpectedly right because when you use
this exclamation mark you're expecting
that there is a value unexpectedly found
nil when unwrapping and optional value
right that is exactly what I was telling
you you're forcing wrapping the title
and you're trying to use it but it was
actually nil so you actually get a crash
and in your career of building apps you
probably will see this error
unexpectedly found nil so now you know
why
so the safer way to go would be actually
to use optional bindings so I'm gonna
press commands that now command Z for
the Americans I'm gonna undo undo all
right do something like that and this is
optional binding so another way where
you can test before using is just whoops
it's just with good old-fashioned if
statement and testing if it's nil so you
can say something like testing for nil
you can say if post title is not equal
nil then print post title and because
you have tested it that it's not nil in
this if statement you can go ahead and
force unwrap that and use it all right
so that works you can safely use force
unwrapping because in this if statement
you've just tested that it's not nil
okay now the reverse if you want to
check that it is nil is post title
equals equals nil
it's not equals nil a lot of beginners
make this mistake and they use one equal
sign but one equal sign is for
assignment remember that so if we're
going to test for nil you're gonna use
two equal signs like that and this is
like optional contains no value okay
optional contains value and in here
for optional binding optional contains
the value so as with all of the other
things we're learning with Swift we can
go deeper there's additional things to
learn about optionals like optional
chaining and other ways of using
optionals but this is your introduction
I wanted to to tell you about what the
question mark means and what the
exclamation mark force unwrapping and
how to check an optional before using it
I wanted to introduce you to these and
high-level concepts and practically
speaking you'll be using them most of
the time like this and then in the
future we'll touch upon the more complex
things about optionals also you might be
wondering why why and when you would
ever use optionals but let me tell you
you definitely will use it when you're
building apps and when we do build our
apps together you'll know what they are
and you'll know how to declare options
and how to unwrap them and how to check
if they're no because you've watched
this lesson okay so thanks for watching
and please subscribe and thumbs up and
share the video with other people you
know who want to learn Swift as well
hello welcome to lesson 14 of the learn
Swift for beginners series in this video
you're going to learn about properties
which is something that we have been
using already together since the class's
lesson but we haven't formally
introduced them yet so this video is for
that in addition to that I'm going to
show you some other cool things you can
do with properties that you can't do
with variables okay so let's get started
so here I have a playground which
defines two classes blog post and person
and you might recognize this from
previous lessons and in both of these
classes we've defined some variables
here
well properties are nothing more than
variables that are associated with a
class like this so for example in this
blog post class I have a title property
body author and number of comments and
if I create a brand new blog post object
from this class let's say let my post
equals new blog post like that and then
in order to access this title property I
would use the dot notation I would say
my post dot title and I'm going to
assign something to this property and
let's just call it title of post like
that and in order to retrieve that value
from that property I would just use dot
notation again and this would return the
value inside that property so you can
see that property is just like a
variable where it stores a value and you
can retrieve it but I don't know if I
mentioned this before and that is that
properties are independent between
objects so remember we have to find this
blog post class right here and from this
class we can create many blog post
objects for instance here I've created a
blog post object and I've assigned it to
my post now let me create a second blog
post object I'm gonna call this my post
too and I'm going to create a brand new
blog post object from there so I have
assigned title of post to the title
property of this guy right here
alright that doesn't affect my new blog
post object so I can assign my post to
thought title equals another title
that and if I display this title you can
see that it shows another title so the
properties are really variables that are
attached to the blogpost objects that I
create and although each blog post
object has a title property the values
that they store are independent of one
another okay so the second thing I
wanted to point out with properties is
that when you're working inside your
class so let's say we're working on this
blog post class and we create some
functions here let's say add comment you
know we're gonna create a function like
that and we're gonna create another
function maybe called share share
article ok these don't really have to do
anything I'm just I just need to create
two functions for the sake of creating
two functions to demonstrate this
purpose okay so just disregard what what
I'm calling them because they're not
really going to do that function okay so
what I wanted to point out is that these
properties that you define inside the
class they can be accessed inside any of
the functions inside that class so
inside add comment you know I might be
performing some code to add a comment
and I would be able to access let's say
you know I can print title or something
like that right that would access this
guy well actually that's an optional so
using what we learned
let me just force unwrap it but my point
is is that I can access these properties
here you know or I can print let's say
body for example you know and here
likewise I can also print body
all right within all of the functions
inside this class I can access any of
these properties up here and I can set
them to from within any of these
functions however if you declare a
variable inside of a function
that is what's called a local variable
and the existence of that variable is
limited to the scope of that function so
what that means in plain English is if I
declare a variable here let's say var my
comment equals you know some comment
like that I would not be able to access
this variable inside this function here
so if I try to you know print my comment
you're gonna see it throw an error here
saying that my comment was never used
oh wait that's regarding this guy right
here so this is just an optimization
Xcode this yellow little triangle means
that it's a warning it's not really an
error so it's fine Xcode is just warning
you that you declared this my comment
variable and you assigned it something
but you never used it so consider
consider changing its name to an
underscore which which is an
optimization but we are going to use it
so Xcode is just proactive because every
time you're typing code it just scans
your code and it tries to tell you about
these optimizations that you can do okay
so that's kind of a side note back to
the main point I was trying to make and
that is if you look at this error here
on use of unresolved identifiers my
comment that means that Xcode doesn't
know what you're referring to when you
try to print my comment here so even
though we declared it here and we
assigned it inside this function this
variable because you declared it inside
here is the scope of this variable or
its existence is limited to whatever is
inside these two curly brackets you know
it's limited to the code inside this
function now if I wanted it to be
accessible everywhere you know I would
create a property and I would use that
instead so that's probably something
you're gonna get used to as you're doing
more coding is the
scope of where you declare things so
this is called the local variable
because we're declaring it inside a
function and these properties that we
declare up here to whole values are
accessible inside the whole class so
what that means is that let me just
delete these two functions for now so
what that means is that if you have a
function that lets say calculates a
result or performs some sort of
calculation like for example add up
comment total or comment counts or
something like that and the point of
this function is to maybe sum up the
number of comments that this blog post
has and then at the end of the whatever
you know you're performing calculations
here um do some calculations and come up
with as a result arrive at a result now
what do you do with that result right
you can either and you learn this in the
functions lesson is that you can specify
a return value so this this specifies
that when you call add up common counts
it's going to return a number for you so
now you can say you know return whatever
the result is whatever variable that's
stored in right you can return it to the
caller another thing that you can do to
make it accessible later on because
remember any variables that you declare
inside here are local variables and they
live and die inside this function here
so if I didn't do the return value route
and I arrived at some sort of calculated
result and I wanted to save it for use
for later on
I would probably assign it to a property
so I can say number of comments equals
whatever result that I arrived at and by
doing this when I call this function
it's gonna do some calculations
calculate the result the total number of
comments right and it's going to assign
it into this property and now I can use
the number of comments in other
functions or later on
if I left it as a local variable it
would again when this function finishes
that would be lost okay so that's the
difference between the lifetime or the
scope of property versus local variables
and now for the third thing that I want
to show you in this lesson is something
called computed properties and it's one
of those things that makes properties a
little more special than just plain old
variables here so let me let me get rid
of these two here so that we can I start
fresh and we're back to where we started
in this lesson you can do what's called
a computed property and what that is is
it just returns and what that is is it
lets you do some calculation and return
a result when you call it property so
let me demonstrate here so let's say
that we have let author equals person
all right so there is our author and
let's set the author's name to Chris
King which is my name and now let's
create a blog post my post equals blog
post okay and now let's assign the
author property of the post right let's
assign author into it now author right
here is this person right this person
object that I created and finally let's
set the title to let's say learn Swift
for beginners
okay so what do we have here we have an
author object which has the name set to
Christian we have a blog post object
with the author set to this person
object that I created and I also set the
title to learn Swift for [ __ ] now
what I wanted to show you is I'm gonna
create a computed property up here I'm
just going to add a comment so that it's
just to make it stand out a little bit
so I can save our full title is a string
and I'm going to open up a set of curly
brackets right right after it and what
I'm going to say is check if title and
author on not nil check that title and
author or not no because title is an
optional all right an author is also an
optional and you learned about these in
the previous lesson so you know what
they mean they could return nil which is
nothing right when you unwrap it so I'm
going to use an if statement just to
check
so if title is not equal to nil and and
that's the double ampersand which
represents an end condition so if title
is not nil and author is also not nil
both of these conditions have to be true
then I'm going to run this code inside
then return title and remember because
title is an optional string right that
means I have to unwrap it to get the
value inside and I'm going to use the
exclamation mark to force unwrap it that
means I'm going to tell Xcode I'm just
going to unwrap that optional and use
whatever is inside whether it's a value
or it's an or whether it's nil and I
know for a fact that it's not nil
because I just checked it up here all
right so I can safely and confidently do
this so I'm going to say
by and then Plus and I'm going to do the
same thing with author I'm just going to
force and wrap it and use it okay so
let's see what it's saying here cannot
be applied to string and person that's
right okay so author is a person right
so I can't I can't append a person
object to the string what I meant to do
actually is I meant to unwrap the author
right to get the person object and then
call its name property so that's what I
actually wanted to do okay so right here
Xcode is complaining that missing
returned in a function expected to
return a string so this computed
property here when it gets called full
title it's supposed to return a string
and if title is not nil and author is
not nil it is going to return a string
but what if one of these things are nil
either or in that case I'm just gonna
use the else branch here I'm just gonna
return let's say let's do another check
else if title is not nil oops
not equals nil then return just the
title oops force and wrap that finally
if the title is nil then I don't know
well we can do other than return an
empty string or let's say no title let's
do that okay so this is awesome now this
is a computed property and I hope you
can see that from this demonstration
what that means it's a property where
basically you can perform some code you
can do some calculation you can combine
a bunch of things and return a result
return something so if I say down here
if I say my host dot full title what do
you think it's going to display
let me print it out because it's kind of
truncated over here let me use the print
so it prints down in the console
it's learn Swift for beginners by
Christian and I didn't have to set that
right because this is a computed
property this full title property is
calculated by grabbing the title and
appending by and then appending the
author name and if we didn't have an
author so let me just let me just get
rid of this line here for setting the
author if we didn't have an author it
would just print out the title and if I
get rid of the title and it doesn't have
a title then it's gonna print no title
and that's all of this logic here in my
computed property okay so that's
computer properties there's also
additional things which we won't cover
in this lesson we'll probably do another
video on properties and that is getters
and setters and property observers but
this is a really great start to taking a
look at properties so thanks for
watching please like the video and
please subscribe
hello welcome to lesson 15 of the learn
Swift for beginners series in this video
we're going to revisit initializers and
I'm going to tell you about designated
initializers and convenience
initializers okay well let's get started
[Music]
so right here I'm starting off again
with the blog post class and the person
class and of these properties here in
the blog post class I'm actually going
to uninitialized some of these
properties so I can demonstrate for you
what we need to do in the initializer
because I mentioned before that one of
the jobs of the initializer is to make
sure that all of these properties are
initialized and ready to go so even if
it is an optional that is considered
okay when you're declaring your
properties inside your class
there are basically three different ways
of doing it so number one is this one
where you declare the property and you
initialize it to some sort of value
right away so that's this body property
right here and this number of comments
property is equal to zero the next thing
you can do is you can declare a property
and set it to optional so you're
specifying that it could be nil or it
could contain a value but either way you
have to unwrap the value and you have to
check if it's nil before using it now
the third way is probably the most
dangerous way and that is using the
force unwrap operator so let me show you
what that means if I get rid of that
question mark and I put an exclamation
mark there and let's also do it beside
author so what you're saying here is
you're saying that title basically is an
optional it could be nil or it could
contain a value but you're going to
leave it unwrapped so when I access the
title property down here and I say post
title Xcode is not going to have that
sort of safe checking or warning us that
it could be nil it's not going to
provide any of those safety mechanisms
and it's just going to let us use it as
is so we can assign nil into title as
you can see here it's nil and we can use
it like a normal property right we don't
have to check if it's nil or not or
rather it is up to us whether we want to
do it or not but however if you know the
difference the flipside being that we
make this an optional
now there are some safety mechanisms in
place if I just try to use this as this
Xcode is going to warn us that hey you
know this is an optional you have to
check that it's not nil or you have to
unwrap it first before you can use it so
I might have to say if let you know
actual title equals and this is using
optional binding so basically we're
checking if there's a value inside the
optional first you know if something
could potentially be nil it's probably
safer to use an optional value so that
it forces the programmer to actually
check things before using it now if you
set your properties like that then it
could still be nil or it could contain a
value but you sort of remove that safety
checking that optionals provide so those
are three different ways that you can
set up your properties what you cannot
do however is you can't just do
something like that where you declare a
property you don't set it to anything
you don't specify that it's an optional
or you don't specify that it's unwrapped
and you just leave it like that
in that case Xcode is going to assume
that the initializer is going to set
those two some values so let's declare
our initializer here like you've learned
in the past and inside here you can see
that Xcode is still showing errors but
if I actually initialize these things
inside the initializer let's say author
is equal to person like that then Xcode
is going to stop complaining because
remember when we create a new blog post
like this it's actually calling the
initializer so even though these
properties right here title and author
they're not set to anything they're not
optionals they're not unwrapped this
initializer is going to be called for
sure when we create a new blog post
object and inside here those properties
get set to some value they get
initialized and so at the end of the day
this blog post object is going to be
ready to be used
now this initializer right here this is
what is called the designated
initializer and what that means is that
this initializer function is guaranteed
to fulfill those obligations of making
sure that all of the properties are
initialized before use in contrast we
can have something that's called a
convenience initializer and what that is
is you use the convenience keyword
followed by your initializer method
signature so I might have something like
this where inside this initializer I
only want to provide a custom title well
you might ask if I call this convenience
initializer how is author going to get
initialized right so what happens is
inside the convenience initializer I
call the designated initializer using
the self keyword like this so now and
inside here let's set title equals
custom title so now when I declare a new
block post object and let's say I use my
convenience initializer like this and I
pass in a custom title like this it's
calling this convenience initializer but
this convenience initializer is also
calling the designated one which makes
sure that at the end of the day you know
the uninitialized properties will be
initialized and then after calling that
designated initializer then we set title
to custom title so whether I call this
designated initializer or the
convenience initializer the title and
the author properties will be guaranteed
to be initialized and so the role of the
convenience initializer is simply for
convenience so that's the difference
between a designated initializer versus
a convenience initializer
hello welcome to learn Swift for
beginners lesson 16 today you're going
to learn about how to manage a
collection of data in what's called an
array if you're working with many pieces
of data it would be hard to manage them
with simply constants and variables so
let's take a look at how arrays can make
our life easier alright let's get
started now arrays are one of three
collection types that are available in
the Swift programming language for us to
use and manage our data in this language
guide you can see a diagram of this
array on the far left side we're going
to come back to this diagram in a second
but first the definition so you can
think of an array as a collection of
data that is ordered by indexes now if
that doesn't tell you too much let's
jump right into a swift playground and
I'll show you exactly how beneficial
they are and also how to declare them
and how to use them so first I'm going
to delete this default variable here and
we're going to create a couple of
variables ourselves so let's say var a
equals dog VAR b equals can't or C
equals bird and now let's say I wanted
to concatenate or add the word my in
front of each of those values there so
that I would have my dog my cat and my
bird so I would have to do something
like this I would have to go a equals my
space plus 8 and this would result in a
being my dog because we're adding the
word my with space to a and a is dog and
then we're reassigning that result into
a again thereby overriding what was
there before so now a is actually my dog
I would have to repeat this for cat and
I'd have to repeat this with bird I
can't even use what we learned in the
previous lessons in regards to loops to
make my life easier I'd have to write
this
three times for each of the variables so
here's the perfect chance to use an
array to organize this collection of
data so in order to create an array with
the data already in it
we're going to open up two angle
brackets or square brackets if you'd
prefer and inside these two square
brackets we put each piece of data
separated by a comma so we have dog we
have cat and we have bird so just like
that we have an array with three pieces
of data and if you remember what I said
in the definition that arrays are a
collection of data organized by indexes
what do I mean by that well you can see
that there are three pieces of data here
so there's three distinct spots you can
think of it the leftmost spot here
the beginning is index 0 or spot 0 if
you'd prefer to think of it like that
the next one is index 1 and the last one
is index 2 so arrays start at 0 and
because there are 3 items here the
indexes go from 0 1 to 2 and now if I
quickly bring up that language guide
again you can see in this diagram that
in this array there are 5 items and so
the index is 4 6 eggs is 0 index from
milk is 1 and so on until it reaches 4
even though there are 5 items because
it's zero-based ok
so let's go back down here so this is
great that we haven't know right here
but we need some way to reference that
array so actually what we do is we can
create a variable let's call it D and we
assign this array or this collection of
data into the variable D so now if I
wanted to access dog for example I would
write D and then I would write square
brackets like that and in between the
square brackets I would put an integer
representing the index of the item that
I want so let's say I want dog I would
put 0 so you can see here I would get
dog right and so we can print that out
and that would print dog down here now
if I change the index to one then I
would get cat instead now let's do an
example where we have something like
this just to duplicate that I would say
let's say a equals my plus D 0 like that
I can do B equals my that's my cat and
finally I would get my bird but then I
mentioned that there was a better way to
do it if we leverage what we learned in
the previous lesson on loops well we can
let's take a look at using for loops and
simplifying our work here so remember
for loops we'll loop a piece of code for
a specified number of times and you can
see here that I'm working with index 0
and X 1 and X 2 so this becomes really
easy I can say for remember the next the
next piece of the for loop is a counter
so you know it's my variable to hold the
current index and then you write in and
then you write your range so I can write
0 0 sorry I mean 0 2 and this is going
to loop from 0 to 2 so I think you can
kind of see where I'm getting at what
I'm gonna do is print my plus D and
inside here where I put the index
usually I'm gonna put counter and you
can see here it took the playground a
little second but that's exactly what I
expect it to do here so in the first
iteration of this for loop counter is 0
right that's the starting range so 0
gets passed in here and I would get this
printed out this is dog D at index 0
right it's dog in the next iteration of
the loop counter is 1 and so I'm
actually
accessing index one of my array d so
that's why I get cat and then finally a
loops again and counter as to and I
would access this bird index here I want
to show you another way to use your for
loop with an array and that's simply to
say for item in D so what this is going
to do is it's going to loop through all
of the items in the array D and in each
iteration of the loop it's going to take
that item or that piece of data and it's
going to assign it to item so I can
simply go like this so you can see that
it gets printed out again right in the
first iteration item is dog in the
second iteration it's cat and the third
it's bird so this is pretty simple way
to write it and you can see that it
saves a lot of work from doing it kind
of one by one like this and one by one
like this arrays in conjunction with
loops really powerful stuff now with a
race there's other cool things you can
do let me just make some space here
maybe I should delete this stuff you can
actually declare an empty array so it's
an array that would contain no data at
first and the way you do that is just
like storing things into a variable or a
constant arrays can only store data of a
certain data type that you specify so
since it's an empty array how you would
do it is you open up two square brackets
you put the data type inside the two
square brackets and that data type
represents the type of the data that the
array is going to store so I'm just
gonna put string here and then you end
off with two round brackets like that
and just like that now e refers to in a
that is empty right now doesn't contain
any data with the intention of storing
string type data in this array now if
you're going to create an empty array
like this you better be able to add data
to that array right so what makes arrays
really useful is that you can add and
remove data from that collection so I
can add or remove from this collection
right here I can add or remove from this
collection here let me just show you how
to do that there are a couple of
different ways I can do something like
this D plus equals to angle brackets
like that again and let's say I wanted
to add mouse and now my D array would
contain four items as you can see here
dog cat bird and mouse in fact I can
even add two pieces of data at once
comma and then here I could put owl for
example so it would add mouse and owl to
that array so now my array has five
items from zero to four right starts at
zero one two three four make sure that
you don't forget that plus sign right
here because if you do that then
essentially you're creating a brand new
array with these two items and you're
assigning it to D and you've just lost
this data here so plus equal is for
adding items now seeing this plus equals
you might be tempted to use minus equals
to remove items like this but that
actually doesn't work unfortunately you
can't remove items from the array like
that what you have to do is the array
actually has functions that you can call
on it to remove items so you would say D
and then you would press dot on your
keyboard or the period key and out pops
a list of functions that you can call on
this array and using the append function
is going to do exactly like this plus
equal is it's going to add items into
that array but let's look at the remove
functions so you have remove all
which is going to remove all the items
in a ray but you can use this one here
remove at and you can specify the index
of the item you want to remove so if I
put 0 like that that's going to remove
dog from my array so now it's only gonna
contain cat bird mouse and owl
now what if I don't want to completely
remove dog but I just wanted to change
that element right there at index 0 so
let me get rid of this removed line you
saw that you can access items in the
array by doing that right putting in the
index there well you can actually change
the item you can change what is assigned
at that index by typing d square
brackets put in the index you want to
change and using the equal sign to
assign something new into that spot so
here let's say turtle and that is going
to now change your array if I print D
oops 0 i'm going to get turtle instead
of dog because i just changed it up here
the last thing i want to point out is
that arrays also you can check how many
items are in there if you look at the
count and that's going to return the
number of items in your array that is
sometimes useful when you want to use a
for loop with a range and you don't know
how many items are in the array you can
use this array dot count and get this
number here but just keep in mind that
although D has 5 items right here the
index of the last item is actually only
4 because the first item is 0 it goes
from 0 1 2 3 4 right even though there
are 5 items so just keep that in mind if
you're going to use this array dot count
in conjunction with a for loop or
something like that okay so that's where
we're going to end with arrays as you
can see when you type array dot there
are a lot of different functions with
arrays that you can do
what I've covered here in this lesson is
enough for you to use a raise and
leverage some of the main benefits of a
raise as we go on and we're building
apps together you're going to be
learning new ways to use a raise but for
now these are the main things you need
to know about a raise in order to start
using them if you like this video please
give this video a thumbs up please
subscribe for more hello welcome to
lesson 17 of the learn Swift for
beginners series in this video we're
going to go through another collection
type called the dictionary in the
previous lesson we went through the
array you can see here on the left hand
side and with an array we had a
collection of items where the order
mattered so you can see in this example
here in the Swift programming language
guide 6 eggs is in spot number 0 whereas
bananas is in index 4 all right well a
dictionary on this right hand side here
is a collection type where order does
not matter so in arrays we retrieve the
item by this index here and with a
dictionary because order doesn't matter
we retrieve these values using a key so
each value has an associated key when
you put it into the dictionary and you
need to pass it that same key and it's
going to return for you the value now
which collection type you use to
organize your data is going to depend on
obviously what sort of data you're
storing it does order matter if it does
then the easy answer is to use an array
if it doesn't then maybe consider using
a dictionary so this is a good example
airports have these airport codes right
so each Airport has an Associated key
and that's a good point the keys should
actually be unique for each value that
you put in another great example if one
to use a dictionary and this is the
example that I'm going to use in this
video is license plates so for example
each license plate is tied to a car and
each license plate is unique so the key
can
the license plate and the value can be
maybe a description of the car or
something like that let's jump into
Xcode in this new playground that I have
here and let me show you how to declare
a new dictionary and how to work with it
so why don't we declare a variable here
and let's call it cardi B to represent
card database and let's looks like my
playground has crashed okay and what
we're going to do here is to declare a
new dictionary so we use the keyword
dictionary and followed by that we have
these angle brackets we're inside we
specify the data type of the key
followed by the data type of the value
so for example let's pull up that
example again in here in this dictionary
the key would be a string and the value
would also be a string and so in between
these two angle brackets we will just
put string comma string and in order to
create a new dictionary object we would
just end off with those two brackets and
like that we have an empty dictionary
which stores key value pairs and a key
value pair is just a fancy name for one
of these pairs of data you know a key
and a value this dictionary stores key
value pairs where the key is a string
and the value is the string as well now
there is an easier way to write this out
without having to write so much let me
show you that second way var car DV
let's just say DB 2 is equal to use the
square brackets and then you specify the
data type of the key followed by colon
and then the data type of the value and
again we have these two brackets here to
create a new instance of that dictionary
or a new dictionary object and that's
equivalent these two are the same thing
doesn't this look very similar to
declaring a brand new array don't get
confused so for example
declaring any string array would look
like this would be my empty array that
is expecting to contain string objects
and this is an empty dictionary that is
expecting to contain key value pairs
where the key is string and value of
string as well okay so we're going to
stick with this sort of declaration here
so I'm just going to go ahead delete
this array example that was just for
demonstration and delete that so now we
just have cardi B is an empty dictionary
now how do I assigned something into the
car database dictionary well I would do
cardi B and then I would use these two
square brackets here and I would pass in
a key or I would specify a key rather
and this key would be a license plate
right so you know this is going to be
different depending where you are in the
world but let's just say it's like that
and then you assign the value into the
dictionary for that key so this would be
let's say a blue Ferrari now this value
blue Ferrari is tied to this key GST 238
how do I retrieve the value well it's
very simple I just give it the key so if
someone were to look up this license
plate let's say I'm a princess out like
that it would print out blue Ferrari but
notice that it's wrapped in an optional
tag because for example if I passed in a
key that doesn't exist right let's pass
in like ASD two three eight then you can
see there is no value for that key all
right so that's why it returns nil so
that's why when you access a dictionary
and you pass in a key it returns to you
an optional whatever data type that your
value is so when you pass in a key into
your dictionary to retrieve a value
just expect that it is an optional and
you may need to unwrap it and check if
it's nil before using it okay so what if
I wanted to let's let's label this so
before we continue on this is declaring
a new dictionary this is adding key
value pairs and this is retrieving data
and how do we update a value for a key
well it looks exactly like this up here
so you specify the key that you want to
update the value for and here we can say
that this guy now is a red Ferrari maybe
it got a paint job or something so when
you pass in this key from now on you're
going to get this new value because this
basically overrode whatever was there
before and in order to remove a value
remove a key value pair let's say you
can do something like this you pass in
the key to 3/8 and you assign it nil and
actually that is going to remove the key
value pair from your dictionary now I'm
going to show you how to iterate over
all of the key value pairs in your
dictionary so why don't we just add a
second key value pair in here so that we
have more than one item to display
okay and this one can be a green
Lamborghini I think that's how you spell
it I don't have one so I don't know for
sure
and now let's iterate over it
wish I had one though iterate over it we
use a for loop so we can say for
essentially for each key value pair
inside the dictionary do something and
the way you specify this is you pass in
we use what's basically called a tuple
okay and so you can think of a tuple as
a set of variables or a bunch of
variables so we'll we're going to say
license car in cardi B now the in key
word shouldn't be new to you because you
guys learned about the for loop in a
previous Swift lesson so basically what
should be new to you though is this this
is a tuple so for each tuple in this
dictionary we can do something what's
gonna happen is it's going to grab each
key value pair and the key is going to
be inside license and the value is going
to be car like that so now inside this
for loop it's going to iterate twice and
I'm going to find this key or this
license inside this license variable and
I'm going to find the car the string
hair blue Ferrari or green Lamborghini
inside this car variable and it knows
even though there's no datatype
associated with this tuple because my
dictionary is string string for the key
and the value I'm going to simply print
a car like that and you can see that hmm
it's just it's printing one key value
pair here it's printing one car but I
have two items
and the reason is because we've actually
removed a key value pair with this
statement here so if I just comment this
guy out we have our two cars and it's a
red Ferrari because we changed it up
here now I can also print out the
license I can say you know license you
know I can say something like car has a
license like that has a license so that
pretty much wraps up using a dictionary
and you're gonna find that it will come
in handy along side arrays in organizing
your data so thanks for watching if you
like this video please give it a thumbs
up and please share it with anyone you
know who's also interested in Swift
thanks for watching I'll see you guys
next time hey did you join my free
Facebook community yet that's where I
hang out along with a ton of other
people learning iOS just like yourself I
also post early access to all of my
videos inside that group before I put
them on YouTube you can also get help
with any questions you're having visit
the link below click on the join group
button and I'll approve your request
right away alright so I'll see you in
there talk soon